TODAY'S HEARING. OF WELCOME TO
THE SENATE LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT THURMOND COMMITTEES
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
CANNABIS AND EMPLOYMENT.
BALANCING SAFETY AND EQUITY IN
A POST PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR
WORKPLACE MOUTHFUL. I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE PARTICIPANTS OR
TAKING TIME TODAY TO BE HERE
AND SHARES SOME OF YOUR WISDOM
AND EXPERTISE WITH US. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE LEARN AS MUCH
AS WE CAN- AND THAT YOU SHARE
YOUR EXPERIENCES WITH THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. CERTAINLY THE
LEGALIZATION OF RECREATIONAL
CANNABIS IN SIXTEEN AND THE
FLURRY OF CANNABIS RELATED
LEGISLATION THAT SEEKS TO KEEP
COMING EVERY YEAR- SINCE
DECISION SINCE THIS APPEARS TO
HAVE TOUCHED EVERY CORNER OF
CAL YET. WE'RE STILL ADJUSTING
TO THE CHANGES WHICH HAVE
RAISED NEW QUESTIONS ABOUT
EMPLOYEE RIGHTS. FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS WORKERS
COMPENSATION AND CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ITSELF THE SUM TOTAL
OF THESE CHALLENGES DEMAND A
MORE COMPLETE AND STICK
EVALUATION I HOPE THAT TODAY'S.
INFORMATIONAL HEARING WILL
PROVIDE A PLATFORM FOR THIS
WIDE RANGE OF EXPERIENCE
STAKEHOLDERS TO INFORM THE
PUBLIC AND HIGHLIGHT AREAS IN
NEED OF FUTURE LEGISLATION. ON
THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC HERE WITH
ME IS- IT WILL BE HERE IS IT
WILL BE A SENATOR MITCHELL WHO
IS JOINING US THIS AFTERNOON
FOR THE HEARING AND ALSO SITS
ON THE COMMITTEE- THE I DID
WANT TO MENTION THAT ALL OF THE
AGENDA OF THE BACKGROUND
INFORMATION IS ON OUR WEBSITE
SO IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A COPY OF
THAT IT WOULD LIKE IT IS THE-
YOU CAN GET IT. ON THE WEBSITE
AND THE ANALYSIS OF THE HE-
BACKGROUND PAPER AND SOME
REASON. THERE SO YOU CAN
CERTAINLY A COMPUTER LIKE. TO
TURN NOW TO OUR FIRST PANEL ON
THE FUTURE. THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF CAL NORMAL GOVERNMENT HERE
IN THE- SITTING HERE BE
WONDERFUL. THANK YOU AND
WELCOME. THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
RUSH TO LEARN MORE. GRANT. RED
MEANS IT'S OFTEN HAD DOES MEDIA
ON. LIKE MY TV I'LL WE WOULD
HAVE THOUGHT THAT THE GREEN
LIGHT SHOWS THAT. HERE IT IS
KIND OF OPPOSITE TO THE AND I
MEAN LIGHTS IS IT'S NOT GOING
ANYWHERE. A GOOD AFTERNOON-
CHAIR GERMAN HILL. THANKS FOR
INVITING ME MY NAME IS IGOR
GRANT- I'M A- PATIENT NURSE CHI
TRISTEN PROFESSOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. AGO
WHERE IDLE DIRECT THE CENTER
FOR MEDICINAL CAN SEARCH. AS
YOU KNOW SOME OF THE PROBLEMS
PROBLEMS OF CALIFORNIANS-
INVOLVED DITIONS LIKE CHRONIC
PAIN POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS
DISORDER. A TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURY INFLAMMATORY DISORDERS.
I CAN SLEEP DISORDERS AND OUR
PATIENTS. I HAVE NOT ALWAYS
BEEN ABLE TO BE TRUE ADEQUATELY
FOR SOME OF THESE CONNECTIONS
GIVEN OUR EGGS MEDICATIONS AND
SO THAT IS A- NEED ALWAYS TO
HAVE MORE TOOLS IN OUR TOOLBOX.
ONE COULD PUT IT THAT WAY. I'M
HERE TODAY TO PROVIDE YOU WITH
MY MEDICAL OPINION- ANNA AND
IT'S BASED ON OUR EXPERIENCE OF
THE CENTER FOR MEDICINAL
CANNABIS RESEARCH WHICH- AS TO
THE STATE OF. KNOWLEDGE ON
MEDICINAL CANNABIS AND
HOPEFULLY THIS WILL BE HELPFUL
IN INFORMING POLICY IN REGARD
TO AND ALSO EDUCATION. CLEARLY
THIS IS A CONTROVERSIAL AREA.
BUT THEY'RE IMPORTANT FACTS
THAT ARE URGING OF FIRSTLY
CENTER FOR MEDICINAL CANNABIS
RESEARCH ITSELF WAS ACTUALLY
ESTABLISHED BY LEGISLATION- OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. UNDER
SB EIGHT FORCE OF AN A IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE CENTS THE.
SENATOR JOHN VASCONCELOS.
REGRET THIS PAST WAY WAS THE
AUTHOR OF THAT LEGISLATION SO
WE- IN TWO THOUSAND. THE CENTER
THE US SB EIGHT FORTY SEVEN WAS
REALLY ALSO TRIGGERED BY
PASSAGE OF PROP TWO FIFTEEN AND
I THINK MAY BE LEGISLATORS WERE
INTERESTED IN WHAT IS THE
SCIENCE IS THE EVIDENCE BASE
FOR MEDICINAL CANNABIS AND SO
THAT WAS- THE- IMPETUS FOR
SETTING UP OR CENTER. SINCE
WE'VE BEEN A STAB LISTED WE ARE
COMPLETED- EIGHT SHORTER TERM
pSTUDIES ON DIFFERENT
CONDITIONS. AND ALL OF THESE-
AS IT TURNS OUT A SHOW THAT IN
THE SHORT TERM- MEDICINAL
CANNABIS WAS BENEFICIAL THE
CONDITIONS WE STUDIED. INCLUDED
NEUROPATHIC PAIN. NO PASSED THE
PAIN AS YOU MAY KNOW IS A
CHRONIC- OF HYPERSENSITIVITY.
ALL THE SERVERS- SYMPTOMS LIKE
TINGLING PAIN- RESPONDING TO A
LIGHT TOUCH IN AN EXAGGERATED
MANNER AND SO FORTH THE END
THIS IS THE KIND OF PAIN THAT'S
PRODUCED BY CERTAIN DISEASES
AND INJURIES INCLUDING HIV AIDS
DIABETES CERTAIN KINDS OF
PHYSICAL INJURIES. DURATION
SOMEWHERE EARLIER. IN THE
NEUROPATHIC PAIN THE REASON I
GO INTO A LITTLE BIT OF DETAIL
IS DIFFERENT THAN THE PAIN YOU
GET SAY AFTER SURGERY- WHERE
YOU HAVE A MORE SEVERE PAIN
IT'S VERY WELL MANAGED BY
OPIOIDS INITIALLY POTENTIALLY
OR NONSTEROIDAL ANTI
INFLAMMATORIES. BUT THE
NEUROPATHIC PAIN DOESN'T
RESPOND WELL TO. THINGS LIKE A
LOW DOSES OF ANTI DEPRESSANTS
AND- ANTIEPILEPTIC DRUGS THING
OF THAT NATURE TO MANAGE THE
HYPERSENSITIVITY AND IT TURNS
OUT. THAT THERE WAS A LOT OF
ANIMAL RESEARCH AND ALSO
INFORMAL HUMAN- REPORT THAT. T.
H. C. PARTICULARLY WAS HELPFUL
SO THAT WAS THE REASON TO
STUDY- NOT PERFECT PARTICULAR
AND AS A SAY FOUND THAT IT IT
WAS USEFUL. IT WAS ABOUT AS
EFFECTIVE AS SOME OF THE
TRADITIONAL MEDICINES SUCH AS
GAP PENTON FOR EXAMPLE. ALSO
LOOK TO ADD MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS
US SPASTICITY AS YOU KNOW I
MESS IS A CHRONIC NEUROLOGICAL
CONDITION. THE BEERS MUSCLES
LIMBS CAN BE A DEBILITATING
SYMPTOMS IN THIS THESE. AND
AGAIN AS WITH NEUROPATHIC PAIN
THERE ARE TREATMENTS BUT NOT A
REPAIRS FUNDS AND SO FORTH SO
AND HERE WE FOUND AGAIN AND ONE
OF OUR STUDIES THAT A TEACH C.
CONTAINING. THIS PRODUCT WAS
HELPFUL. IT ACTUALLY ARE. OF
WHICH WERE PUBLISHED SOMETIME
AGO WERE MUCH ECHOED IN THE
MORE RECENT REPORT. YOU KNOW
FROM THE NATIONAL. ALBUM OF
SCIENCE ENGINEERING AND
MEDICINE. HE SEVENTEEN REVIEWED
IN A MASSIVE AWAY ALL OF THE
DATA ABOUT THAT AND THEY REACH
THE CONCLUSION FACT IT'S THEIR
TERM THERE IS CONCLUSIVE
EVIDENCE THAT FOR CERTAIN
CONDITIONS LIKE NORA MATH YOUR
PATH MAIN OF SPASTICITY IN
MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS A CONTROL
OF- CERTAIN SYMPTOMS OF WEIGHT
LOSS. AND NAUSEA THAT THERE WAS
PRETTY CONCLUSIVE EVIDENCE THAT
OF THESE TASTY CONTAINING WERE
USEFUL SO- I THINK THE DATA ARE
FAIRLY CLEAR ON THAT WHAT IS
UNCLEAR IS THE USEFULNESS IN
THE LONG TERM AND ALSO WHETHER
OR THERE ARE SUB GROUPS OF
PATIENTS WHERE WE NEED TO
EXERCISE GREATER CAUTION. WELL
FOR EXAMPLE ELDERLY PEOPLE WHO
MAY RESPOND TO- A TEACH THE
CONTAINING PRODUCT WITH MORE
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT OF OUR
PROBLEMS ALONG THOSE LINES THAT.
MIGHT A HEALTHY FORTY YEAR OLD
FOR EXAMPLE. ALL THE OTHER-
CANNABINOID THAT HAS BECOME
VERY- MUCH OF INTEREST IS
CANNABIDIOL. NO CANNABIDIOL IS
A NATURALLY OCCURRING
CANNABINOID IT IT IT'S FOUND IN
IN MARIJUANA THE DEPENDING ON
THE CULTIVARS THE PLANTS
THEMSELVES OF SOME PRODUCE
ALMOST NONE SOME PRODUCE A LOT
HAMPER FOR EXAMPLE IS BASICALLY
CAM. THE DIVA. MARIJUANA BUT IT
JUST DOESN'T PRODUCE THC IT
COULD BE ENGINEERED TO PRODUCE
IT BUT IT DOESN'T HAPPEN TO IN
A IN A NATURAL ENVIRONMENT.
SOSA CABA THEY ALL HAS- BEEN
THOUGHT OF BEING POTENTIALLY
FULL AS AN ANTI INFLAMMATORY
DRUG AGAIN AN ANTIEPILEPTIC
DRUG. AND POTENTIALLY HAS OTHER
ACTIONS INCLUDING ANTIANXIETY.
ANY PSYCHOTIC ACTIONS SO THESE
ARE SOME OF THE AREAS THAT ARE
BEING EXPLORED. IN IN FACT
UNDER- THE CENTER FOR MEDICINAL
CANNABIS RESEARCH WHICH NOW
RECEIVES FUNDING- FROM PROP
SIXTY FOUR FOUR. A WE HAVE- NOW
OF SELECTED FIVE STUDIES GO
FORWARD- WITH THESE FUNDS TO IN
FACT STUDY OF THE POSSIBLE USE
OF CANNABIS. SCHIZOPHRENIA IN
ANOREXIA. SEVERE THIS IS A
WEIGHT LOSS CONDITION AFFECTING
PRIMARILY YOUNG WOMEN. IN
RHEUMATOID ARTHRITIS WHICH IS
AN INFLAMMATORY CHRONIC
ARTHRITIC. CONDITION IT ALSO IN
INSOMNIA I DIDN'T MENTION THAT
EARLIER BUT OBVIOUSLY PROBLEMS
ARE AMONG THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE. HI AND
IT'S CLEAR THAT- BUT THE
REGULAR OR INCREASING USE OF-
CERTAIN KINDS OF SLEEPING PILLS
IS NOT A GREAT THING SOME
PEOPLE DO IT FINE BUT WITH SOME
PEOPLE BECOMES PROBLEMATIC AND
AGAIN THERE'S SOME SUGGESTION
THAT CANNABIDIOL WERE KIND OF A
DIAL IN COMBINATION VERY LOW
DOSES OF THC MAY BE HELPFUL IN
SLEEP PROBLEMS AND MAY BE LESS
PROBLEMATIC. IN THE LONG TERM.
THE OTHER AREA THAT'S
IMPORTANT. AND VERY TIMELY NOW
IS THE- POSSIBILITY THAT
CANNABINOIDS MAY HAVE AN OPIOID
SPARING EFFECT WITH THE
PROBLEMS THAT HAVE OCCURRED
WITH- OPIOID OVERDOSES. AND
EITHER OVER PRESCRIPTION OR
ILLICIT USE OF BOYS- THERE IS
AN INTEREST AND SOME DATA TO
SUGGEST THAT THE COMBINATION OF
CANNABINOIDS WITH VOIGTS
ACTUALLY REDUCES THE AMOUNT OF
OPIOID THAT NEEDS TO BE
PRESCRIBED OR MILLION IN FACT
EVEN SUBSTITUTE FOR THE
OPIOIDS. BUT IT'S A
SCIENTIFICALLY OPEN QUESTION AS
A SAY THERE SOME DATA BUT
THAT'S I THINK AN EXCITING
DIRECT THAT NEEDS TO BE
EXPLORED. WELL I'VE TALKED
ABOUT SOME. BUT IN SOME
BENEFITS SO IT WOULD BE REMISS
NOT TO TALK ABOUT PROBLEMS AS
WELL- IN AND SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS- THAT- THAT CAN OCCUR-
ARE OF COURSE. IF A CANNABINOID
CONTAINS THC PARTICULARLY IT
MAY IMPAIR MEMORY COORDINATION
JUDGMENT- ALERTNESS VARIOUS
THINGS LIKE THAT DEPENDING ON
THE DOSE OF THE US TO FIX OF
THE PERSON HOW THEY HANDLE IT.
SO THESE CAN BE PROBLEMATIC
AREAS OF WATER THERE ARE
STUDIES THAT WE HAVE BEEN- DO
IT IS JUST COMPLETE IS
ACTUALLY- STUDY ALL OUR HOME
THE EFFECTS ON DRIVING. IN
PEOPLE WHO USE DIFFERENT. NOT
USE BUT ARE GIVEN ACTUALLY IN A
LABORATORY SETTING A DIFFERENT
CONCENTRATIONS OF THC
CONTAINING PRODUCT AND SO- THAT
WAS- UNDER- AB TWO SIXTY SIX
ACTUALLY- MISTER LACKEYS
LEGISLATION THAT OF THE SYSTEM.
SO WE ARE ARE LOOKING FORWARD
TO THE RESULTS OF THAT- AND
PARTICULARLY LOOKING AT- WHAT
KINDS OF IMPROVE BEHAVIORAL AND
ROADSIDE TESTING MAY BE.
APPLICABLE BY CHP OFFICERS OR
WHOEVER OF. THAT MAY GO BEYOND
WHAT WE DO NOW. NOT ONE OF THE
THINGS I KNOW THAT'S OF
INTEREST TO THIS GROUP IS. WELL
WHAT IS THE EFFECT ON THE-
EMPLOYEE IF SOMEBODY HAS A
CHRONIC CONDITION. ARMED AND TO
ME- ONE ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED FULL ON IS OF THE
ISSUE OF CHEMICAL TESTING AND
WHETHER THE CHEMICAL TESTING
CAN BE A SUBSTITUTE FOR IF YOU
WILL BEHAVIORAL TESTING OF THE
EMPLOYEE. OF THE DIFFERENCE IN-
CANNABINOID CHEMISTRY OR
PHARMACOLOGY IS THAT JUST
BECAUSE SOMEONE HAS SOME SAY H.
C. IN THEIR SYSTEM. DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEAN THEY'RE
IMPAIRED AND DOESN'T TELL YOU
MUCH ABOUT WHEN THEY TOOK IT-
AND SO- USING A KIND OF PER SE
APPROACH. IT IS NOT A USEFUL
THING AND WE HAVE FOUND THIS
THROUGH THE DRIVING STUDIES
THAT ACTUALLY DRIVING
IMPAIRMENT CORRELATED POORLY
WITH TWO WITH A BLOOD LEVELS
AND SO LIVE AND BREATH LOVELL'S
ON CANNABINOIDS. SO WAS THE ONE
THAT SHOULD BE CONSIDERED IN MY
JUDGMENT IS IN THE EMPLOYEE.
PLEASE TESTING SOMEBODY- MAY OR
MAY NOT TELL YOU IF THEM HE IS
ACTUALLY ABLE TO DO THERE. AND
IN FACT SOMETIMES ONE MIGHT
REACH THE WRONG CONCLUSION. SO
I THINK THAT I'D LIKE TO
SUMMARIZE BECAUSE I'M FROM SURE
TIME IS SHORT THE BUT AND I DO
HAVE THE STATEMENT WHICH
LOGICAL BUT YOU CAN TAKE A LOOK
AT. A BUT I WOULD OFFER THE
FOLLOWING OF THE THINGS FOR
CONSIDERATION. WE WILL BENEFIT
OUR PATIENTS SCHERING THAT
PHYSICIANS AND OTHER MEDICAL
STE. RECEIVE EDUCATION FIRST ON
THE POTENTIAL VALUE OF
MEDICINAL ALKALOIDS AS WELL AS
THEIR SIDE EFFECTS AND POSSIBLE
HARMS. INCLUDING WHAT REMAINS
UNKNOWN. OF THE IT SHOULD BE
ACKNOWLEDGED THEIR MAIN MANY
SUCH UNKNOWNS. GIVEN THE STILL
EVOLVING FIELD OF CANNABINOID
SEARCH. WE SHOULD ENCOURAGE
HEALTH PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE
UNBIASED AUTHORITATIVE
INFORMATION. ON PATIENT ON A
MEDICINAL CANNABIS AND
CANNABINOID. IF THE PATIENT'S
CONDITION OF MAYBE BENEFITTED
BASED ON THE SCIENCE THAT'S
EMERGING. OF WE ALSO WOULD- PUT
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THAT
PATIENTS WHO RECEIVE MEDICINAL
CANNABIS IN A MANNER COMPLIANCE
WITH STATE. SHOULD NOT BE
SUBJECTED TO ANY ADVERSE ACTION
IN REGARD TO THEIR EMPLOYMENT
EDUCATION OR OTHER BENEFITS AS
A CONSEQUENCE. AND THAT ARE IN
COOPERATION WITH THE MEDICAL
BOARD WE CONTINUE TO DEVELOP
PROTOCOLS AND DECISION TREES
GOT THIS CANNABIS AND
CANNABINOID ADMINISTRATION
BASED ON THE EMERGING SCIENCE
I'M I'D SAY WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE SCHOOL BOARD ALREADY
ON THEM. FINAL THAT EMPLOYERS
AND THOSE IN CHARGE OF
EDUCATIONAL ISSUE. SHOULD
RECEIVE INFORMATION ON HOW TO
ACCOMMODATE EMPLOYEE STUDENTS
WITH WOULD THAT NEEDS FOR
MEDICINAL CANNABIS IN THEIR
PLACES OF. SPECIFICALLY
EMPLOYEES AND STUDENTS WHO
RECEIVE A DISCOUNT SHOULD NOT
BE JUDGED TO BE IMPAIRED OR
UNQUALIFIED BASED ONLY ON
CHEMICAL TESTS. BUT INSTEAD
SHOULD BE EVALUATED BASED ON
BEHAVIORAL ASSESSMENTS THAT ARE
RELEVANT TO THEIR OCCUPATION BE
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE DO WITH
AIRLINE PILOTS FOR EXAMPLE. WE
TEST WHETHER THEY CAN ACTUALLY
DO THE JOB. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION ONE ZERO THANK YOU
MISTER GRANT AND I WANT TO
WELCOME SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK
YOU FOR THE GREAT TO SEE YOU
TODAY. IT MAY BE THE ORDER TO
DO WELL. BEFORE WE GO ON A
JUST. A COUPLE QUESTIONS AND
COMPARE THE MIND IN A- NOTICE
THE TERM I HAVE A- ARTICLE FROM
COVENTRY REGENERATIVE. AT THE
COMPANY I GET RID OF THE NATION
OF THAT NATURE TALK. THIS IN
THE TREATMENT OF SOME DIFFERENT.
ELEMENTS TALKS ABOUT THE
NEUROPATHIC PAIN AND AN AGREED
WITH THAT BUT I GUESS TO DO
GOING TO YOUR POINT THAT A LOT
OF THIS IS STILL UNCLEAR. TO
SOME OF THE BENEFITS EIGHT.
STATE THAT THERE ARE. SURE WELL
CANNELLA WOODS- IS IN MULTIPLE
SCLEROSIS RELATED TREMORS AND
THAT SO IT WOULD I GUESS WHAT
I'M IN OF THE TAKE AWAY FOR ME
ISN'T THERE STILL SOME
CONTROVERSY OR DISCUSSION FOR
WHAT ACTUAL OR DERIVED FROM
SOME OF THESE CANNABIS PRODUCTS
AND I THINK YOU SURE YOU
MENTIONED THAT IN YOUR- YOUR
PRESENTATION. THAT'S CORRECT
THE FIELD IS THE- I THINK THE-
AS OF ABOUT A YEAR AGO THE MOST
AUTHORITATIVE DOCUMENT IS THIS
NATIONAL ACADEMIES REPORT BUT
AS THEY SAY IT'S THOUSANDS OF
PAGE ACTUALLY BUT IT'S ALSO
SUMMARIZED IN IN IN VERY NICE
ABSTRACT THAT EACH SECTION. AND
I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT
FOR NEUROPATHIC PAIN AND FOR
MUST PULL. SPASTICITY I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THEY MEAN BY TREMORS
THAT'S ANOTHER SITUATION
WHETHER OF TREMORS ARE BENEFIT
I DON'T I DON'T THINK THAT'S
BEEN STUDIED SUFFICIENTLY BUT
FOR SPASTICITY MASS THERE'S
VERY GOOD EVIDENCE NOW I
BELIEVE. WE ARE ACTUALLY
CONDUCT. THE ON SOMETHING
CALLED ESSENTIAL TREMOR WHICH
IS A CONDITION. MAY AFFECT
OLDER PEOPLE IN PARTICULAR
ERROR A PRODUCT CONTAINING CB
DE HELLO BUT IF THC IS BEING
TESTED BY ONE ROGER SO WE MAY
GET SOME MORE INFORMATION ON A
LEASE THAT TYPE OF TREMOR. I
THINK IN THE OTHER AREAS THE
FIELD IS EVOLVING THAT'S TRUE.
OF AND- MORE WELL WHAT CAN YOU
EXPECT THE SCIENTISTS SAY MORE
RESEARCH NEEDS TO BE DONE OF
COURSE. NATURALLY. WHAT DO YOU
DO FOR A I DIDN'T MEAN TO ABOUT
FACE YOU'RE HERE YEAH AND DO
YOU FEEL THAT THE OF
UTILIZATION OF LOCAL MARIJUANA
WITHIN THE WORKERS COMPENSATION
TIM COULD REDUCE THE USE OF- IN
PAIN KILLERS. YES. I THINK IT
COULD AND IF IT THERE I THINK
IT COULD I CAN SAY THAT WITH
CERTAINTY. BUT CERTAINLY THE
EVIDENCE. ALSO FROM PRICKLY
WELL RESEARCH WITH ANIMAL TYPES
OF DATA. SUGGEST THAT YOU COULD
PROBABLY REDUCE. THE AMOUNT OF
OPIOID PEOPLE NEED. AND A
DOCTOR MARK WALLACE YOUR PAIN
PROGRAM AT UC SAN DIEGO HAS
SAID THAT. MANY PATIENTS HAVE
SPONTANEOUSLY COME TO HIM HE IS
A CHRONIC PAIN PROGRAM. WHO
SAID YOU KNOW ONCE I STARTED
YOU KNOW USING MARIJUANA I
DON'T FEEL LIKE. IT SO THAT
BEEN EVEN A SPONTANEOUS. A
SCIENTIFIC OUT OF FORMAL STUDY
BUT- I THINK THERE'S PROBABLY A
THERE THERE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WHICH I APPRECIATE THAT TO
AND THE TESTIMONY IS VERY
HELPFUL OKAY. WHICH YOU'RE
WELCOME. ALLEN GOOD AFTERNOON.
DIRECTED DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
NORMAL I AM. A LOT OF THE TREE
HERE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR HILL SENATOR MITCHELL
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY YES MY NAME IS OWN
COMBINE THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA NORMAL WHICH IS THE
STATE CHAPTER OF THE NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION FOR THE REFORM OF
MARIJUANA LAWS WE ARE A NON
PROFIT MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION
THAT HAS ADVOCATED FOR CANNABIS
CONSUMERS AND EVIDENCE BASED
POLICIES IN CALIFORNIA SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY. TWO. EVEN
THOUGH CANNABIS IS NOW LEGAL
FOR ADULT USE AND HAS BEEN
LEGAL FOR MEDICAL USE SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY SIX IN
CALIFORNIA. WORKERS IN OUR
STATE CAN STILL BE FIRED OR
DENIED EMPLOYMENT FOR TESTING
POSITIVE FOR CANNABIS. EVEN IF
THEY USED IT DAYS BEFORE OR
NEED TO TREAT A SERIOUS
ILLNESS. THE RESULT IS TO
UNFAIRLY DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
QUALIFIED WORKERS DENY THE
MEDICAL TREATMENT WITH CANNABIS
AND OFTENTIMES COMPELLED TO
DEPEND ON OPIATES OR MORE
HAZARDOUS DRUGS. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT RULED
THAT MEDICAL MARIJUANA USE IS
NOT PROTECTED UNDER THE STATE'S
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HELP ACTOR
FEE HA. THE LEGISLATURE
RESPONDED BY PASSING A BILL TO
REVERSE THIS DECISION BUT IT
WAS VETOED BY GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER. PROP SIXTY FOUR
BY CALIFORNIA VOTERS IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO LEGALIZED THE ADULT
USE OF CANNABIS DID NOT PROTECT
EMPLOYMENT RIGHTS OF
RECREATION. MEDICAL CANNABIS
USERS. LAST YEAR A BILL WAS
INTRODUCED IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE THAT WOULD HAVE
PROTECTED THE RIGHTS OF
EMPLOYEES USING MEDICAL
CANNABIS. BUT IT DID NOT
ADVANCE. CAL NORMAL HAS HER
COUNTY SAID REPORTS OF MEDICAL
USERS WHO HAVE BEEN FIRED OR
DENIED EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE THEY
TESTED POSITIVE FOR MARIJUANA
AND MANY SAY THEY HAVE HAD TO
INCREASE THEIR USE OF OPIATES
OR OTHER MEDICATIONS BECAUSE OF
DRUG TESTING POLICIES.
CALIFORNIA LAGS BEHIND OTHER
STATES ON THIS IMPORTANT HUMAN
RIGHTS ISSUE SIXTEEN OTHER
STATES AND WASHINGTON DC HAVE
ENACTED STATUTES PROTECTING
QUALIFIED MEDICAL CAN OF.
SERVERS FROM WORKPLACE DISK
NATION YOU CAN SEE THE STATE'S
ON THE MAP AND BY THE WAY THEY
INCLUDE ARKANSAS OKLAHOMA WEST
VIRGINIA CURRENTLY MORE
PROGRESSIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
ADDITIONALLY STATE COURTS IN
SIX STATES HAVE OW RULED THAT
MEDICAL CANNABIS USERS CANNOT
BE FIRED OR DENIED EMPLOYMENT
FOR OFF THE JOB CANNABIS USE OR
FAILING TO PASS THE- EMPLOYMENT
DRUG SCREEN. SIMILARLY COURTS
ARE BEGINNING TO RULE FAVORABLY
REGARDING WORKERS COMPENSATION
AND CANNABIS. A GREAT MANY
STUDIES LOOKING AT THE RENTAL
OF AT LEAST TWENTY THOUSAND
STUDIES ON CANNABIS A GREAT
MANY HAVE SHOWN CANNABIS IS OF
TO FOR PAIN AND CAN ALLOW
PATIENTS TO REDUCE USE OF
OPIATES YET CALIFORNIA IS NOT
ALLOW FOR CANNABIS AS A CHRONIC
PAIN TREATMENT FOR. WORKERS
COMPENSATION. RECENTLY THE
STATE OF MAINE AND THE VATA AND
NEW YORK CITY HAVE MOVED TO
PROTECT THE EMPLOYMENT RIGHTS
OF THE ATION- CANNABIS USERS.
AGAINST PRE EMPLOYMENT DRUG
SCREEN. CALIFORNIA LABOR CODE
CURRENTLY ALLOWS EMPLOYEE
CLAIMS FOR QUOTE JUST CHARGE
FOR. MEANT FOR LAWFUL CONDUCT
OCCURRING DURING NON WORKING
HOURS AND QUOTE. THIS MAY BE UP
ONLY ONCE FEDERAL LAW CHANGES.
I WANTED TO PUT AN ELEPHANT ON
THE SLIDE BUT- THE ELEPHANT IN
THE ROOM THE FEDERAL LAW. ALL
THIS STATE LEVEL PROGRESSES
HAPPENED DESPITE FEDERAL
GENUINE TO KEEP BOTH MEDICAL
AND RECREATIONAL MARIJUANA
ILLEGAL. FEDERAL LAW MANDATES
RANDOM URINE TESTING WITH NO
EXCEPTIONS FOR MARIJUANA FOR
SAFETY SENSITIVE POSITIONS LIKE
TRUCK IN SCHOOL DRIVERS AN-AIRLINE PILOTS. IN ADDITION
CERTAIN FEDERAL GRANTEES ARE
REQUIRED TO MAINTAIN A DRUG
FREE WORKPLACE. ALL THE STATE
LAWS I HAVE MENTIONED AND THE
EMPLOYMENT RIGHTS LAWS WE ARE
PROPOSING IN CALIFORNIA EXEMPT
EMPLOYERS WHO ARE SUBJECT. AND
DATES SO THAT THEY DON'T USE
FEDERAL CIRCUIT LOSE FEDERAL
CERTIFICATION OR FUNDING. IT
SHOULD BE EMPHASIZED THAT URINE
SCREENS FOR MARIJUANA IN NO WAY
MEASURE ACTUAL JOB FITNESS OR
IMPAIRMENT. THIS IS BECAUSE
THEY DETECT NON ACTIVE
METABOLITES THAT RESIDE IN THE
SYSTEM FOR DAYS OR WEEKS AFTER
USE. NOT A SINGLE CONTROLLED
FTA STUDY HAS EVER SHOWN THAT
URINALYSIS IS EFFECTIVE IN
IMPROVING. SAFETY. IN GENERAL
STATES LIKE CALIFORNIA THAT
ALLOW LEGAL USE OF MARIJUANA
TEND TO HAVE LOWER RATES OF
WORKPLACE FATALITIES THAN
PROHIBITIONISTS STATES.
SCIENTIFIC REVIEWS HAVE NOT
FOUND ANY GOOD EVIDENCE THE
CANNABIS IS ASSOCIATE PATIENT-
INJURIES AND STUDIES HAVE EVEN
SUGGESTED THAT WORKERS WHO
TESTED POSITIVE CANNABIS WERE
LESS LIKELY TO BE INVOLVED IN
WORKPLACE ACCIDENTS OF A TOP.
THEN THOSE WHO TESTED DRUG FREE.
BETTER LTERNATIVES URINE
TESTING EXISTS FOR JOBS
INVOLVING HIGHLY ST CENTURY
LIVES SITUATIONS. SUCH TESTS
HAVE THE ADVANTAGE OF DETECTING
IMPAIRMENT DUE TO ANY SOURCE BE
IT CANNABIS DRUGS FATIGUE OR
MEDICAL FACTORS. COMPANIES THAT
SWITCHED TO THIS KIND OF
TESTING HAVE. LOWER WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS AND
INCREASE PRODUCTIVITY. ANOTHER
ALTERNATIVE TO BURN TEST COULD
BE ORAL BOB A BREATH TEST NOW
UNDER DEVELOPMENT WHICH MAY BE
ABLE TO NARROW DETECTION WINDOW
TO WITHIN A FEW HOURS IS DR
GRANT POINTED OUT THERE ARE
SOME ISSUES WITH THAT
CORRELATING THAT WITH
IMPAIRMENT. OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
ARE ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
CURRENT OPIOID EPIDEMIC.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD EXTEND FEE
HOW WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS TO
GRANT MEDICAL CANNABIS PATIENTS
THE SKIN RIGHTS TO REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION AS THOSE TAKING
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. WORKERS
COMPENSATION LAWS AND
REGULATIONS SHOULD BE AMENDED
TO ALLOW CAN FOR CHRONIC PAIN
TREATMENT AND IF POSSIBLE CON
PATIENTS FOR COSTS OF MEDICAL
CANNABIS. THE CALIFORNIA SHOULD
ALSO BàN URINE TESTING OR
TESTING FOR INACTIVE
METABOLITES FOR CANNABIS AND
RANDOM OR PRE EMPLOYMENT DRUG
SCREENS IN PUBLIC AND PRIVATE.
EXCEPT AS REQUIRED BY FEDERAL
LAW. WE SHOULD ENCOURAGE AND
DEVELOP PERFORMANCE TESTING AND
POSSIBLY ORAL. REST TESTING OF
THE ALTERNATIVES FOR SAFETY
SENSE SESSIONS. SO THIS IS A
VERY. FOR MUCH A SUMMARY OF THE
DATA I HAVE I A ARE ALSO ALWAYS
AVAILABLE FOR CONSULTATION ON
THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ME. VERY INFORMATIVE THE YES
THE. THE MAIN TAKE AWAY FOR ME
IS OR THERE'S. NO SOLUTION. IS
GREAT IS THE SOLUTION FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CHANGING THEIR
POLICIES AND. FOR CALLING FOR
ANY THIS ITS TRUE L. ACROSS THE
BOARD IN. I WANNA SURE. YOU
KNOW OF THE STATE'S OF THE
LABORATORIES OF DEMOCRACY RIGHT
NOW A LOT OF STATES ARE MOVING
FORWARD WITH IT AND WITHOUT THE
DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS FROM WHAT
WE'VE SEEN IN THE STUDY SO FAR.
AND YOU SEE THAT THE TESTING.
THE WORKPLACE TESTING LIKE A-
AND I'M NOT AWARE OF THE- THE
CHALLENGES THAT EMPLOYEES ARE
FACED WITH- AND HAVE BEEN IN
THE STRUGGLES THAT THEY IN THE
STATISTICS CERTAINLY POINT THAT
OUT. HAVE YOU FOUND THAT THE.
USE OF THAT OF TESTING AND
THERE IS A WAY OF TESTING THAT
DISH THE WITH THE SWAB AND THE
BLOOD WHATEVER IS THE SWAB TEST
WHICH WOULD INDICATE THE THC
LEVELS RATHER THAN THE- LONG
TERM. TWO WEEKS AFTER- AND YOU
CAN TO DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
THE TWO YEAH THIS IS A SHOWN
PROMISE IT POSSIBLE. TO DO THAT
BUT- DR GRANT POINTS OUT IN THE
STUDIES ARE BEING YOU KNOW
DEPENDING PERSONS. THE AIR WAS
CANNABIS AND STUFF IN THE
DISTANCE THAT THEY'RE USING AND
STUFF IT MIGHT NOT ACTUALLY
CORRESPOND TO THEIR IMPAIRMENT
IT ALSO DOESN'T WORK IF YOU
TAKE IT ORALLY. IRONICALLY
YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE SMOKE IN
YOUR MOUTH SO- WITH REALLY
THINK FOCUS SHOULD BE ON
PERFORMANCE TESTING OR THE TYPE
OF YOU KNOW WHAT THE AIRLINE
PILOTS DO IS DR GRANT SAID
BECAUSE AGAIN THAT COULD PICK
UP YOU MIGHT BE OF FIFTEEN YOU
MIGHT BE EMOTIONALLY STRESSED
AND SO IF THE CONCERN IS
ACTUALLY WORKPLACE SAFETY. THEN
WE OUGHT TO BE LOOKING AT
PERFORMANCE TESTING INSTEAD OF
CHEMICAL TESTING. VERY GOOD
INTERESTING. DO I FOR YOUR
PREVIOUS FIVE AS I SIT HERE IN
AND SEND TO YOUR RESPONSE TO
SENATOR HILL YOU KNOW I WONDER
SENATOR HE'LL IT THIS REALLY IS
A CULTURAL ISSUE AROUND I'M
BIASED AGAINST THE PRODUCT
FUNDAMENTALLY. YOU I MEAN
BECAUSE I MEAN WE CAN I WANTED
TO LOOK AT YOUR RECOMMENDATIONS
AGAIN BUT I WONDER IF IT'S. HI
IF WILL EVER GET THERE IF WE
CAN CAN YOUTO A TO A TECH TO
ATTACK. APPROACH FROM RATIONAL
PERSPECTIVE BUT IS IT REALLY
JUST A FUNDAENTALLY A
FUNDAMENTAL CULTURE SHIA- WHERE
THERE'S A BIAS AGAINST THE
PRODUCT YOU KNOW AS OPPOSED TO
UNFORTUNATELY PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS. THAT CAN HAVE MUCH MORE
VERSE IMPACT IN THE HISTORIC
BUT AT HIS DOOR. HOLD TWO MEN
AND ALCOHOL AND WELL YOU KNOW
ALL TRULY. ALCOHOL GROUP ALL
THOSE ARE DEEMED ACCEPTABLE.
USING THE TERM LOOSELY- BUT I
GUESS I JUST IT MAKES ME AS I
LISTEN TO THE RATIONALE INTER
LIKE YOU SAID THAT THAT THAT IF
THE IF THE CONCERN IS
LEGITIMATELY SAFETY. THE TEST
WERE TESTING FOR THE WRONG
THING YES I THINK IT'S GIVE
EMPLOYERS SOMETIMES A FALSE
SENSE OF SECURITY BECAUSE THERE.
IMPAIRMENT IT'S NOT A GOOD WAY
TO. FIFTY IT'S JUST A GREAT WAY
TO DISCRIMINATE AGAINST PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO USE MARIJUANA ON
THE WEEKENDS INSTEAD OF SOME.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE
THAT THAT WAS WONDERFUL. NOW GO
TO PANEL NUMBER TWO CAN OF
INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDERS MORGAN
LOCAL EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT
OF REGULATORY AFFAIRS FOR MAD
MEN. IN LINDSEY ROBINSON DIRECT
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. TO SEE YOU AND
ERIC CARR C. E. O. OF FULL MAY
A NAPA BASED CANNABIS RETAILER.
QUESTION EIGHT THIS WILL BE A
GREAT TOPIC THANK YOU AGAIN.
OVER THERE. CANNELLA OKAY. AMY
YOU DON'T LOOK LIKE LINDSAY
ROBINSON. IMAGE YOU'RE FILLING
IN YOUR FILL IN TODAY YOU'RE
DOING A GREAT WILL DO A GREAT
JOB OF IT SO THANK YOU. THE
MORGAN YOU PLEASE. BEGIN THIS
ISSUE HI THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND SENATOR
MITCHELL FOR- INVITING ME TO
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S HEARING
MY NAME IS MORGAN SO CLIMB
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT OF
REGULATORY AFFAIRS AT MAD MEN
WHICH MEANS THAT I OVERSEE THE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS COMPLIANCE
AND LET. AND SING TEAMS AT THE
COME. FOUNDED IN TWENTY TEN IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT IS NORTH
AMERICA'S. IN SIX DIFFERENT
STATES WITH THIRTY TO OPERATE
ALL RETAIL LOCATIONS OVER
TWELVE HUNDRED STAFF AND A
PROCESS OVER TO. RETAIL
TRANSACTIONS TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE
BELIEVE A WORLD WHERE CANNABIS
IS LEGAL AND RIGHT PLATED IS
SAFER HEALTHIER AND HAPPIER. A
I WILL FOCUS MY COMMENTS ON
EFFORTS TO. DIVERSE WORKFORCE
IT MEANT TO SOCIAL EQUITY
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
HOW WE APPROACH CORPORATE
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY
ESPECIALLY IN TERMS OF. THE
HARMS WARRANT DRUGS IS THIS.
THEY HAD ON COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. WE ARE PROUD OF OUR
PARTNERSHIPS COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS WITH THE
UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS UNION MADE PARTNERS
WITH UFCW TO RAISE STAND
WORKERS OF US THE INDUSTRY AND
TO SET THE GOLD STANDARD FOR
WORKERS RIGHTS AND PROTECTIONS.
ALL OF OUR CALIFORNIA RETAIL
EMPLOYEES REPRESENTED BY UFC W.
WE PAY A LIVABLE COMPETITIVELY
THIS OFFER A BONUS INCENTIVE
PRO AND PROVIDE FULL HEALTH
CARE BENEFITS NO MATTER IT
PLEASE PART TIME OR FULL TIME
AND GIVEN THAT WERE PUBLICLY
TRADED IN CANADA WE ALSO OFFER
EMPLOYEE STOCK OPTIONS IN THE
COMPANY. IN TERMS OF DIVERSITY
EQUITY AND INCLUSION AND AT OUR
COMPANY WILL DOES TWO PRONGED
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION. WE
PARTICIPATE IN LOCAL JOB FAIRS
WE HOPE OWN JOB FAIRS AND WE
PARTNER WITH CITY AND STATE
AGENCIES TO SPREAD THE WORD OF
OUR HIRING INITIATIVE. OUR HEAD
OF TALENT ACQUISITION HAS BUILT
A GREAT WORKING RELATIONSHIP
WITH PATRICK HANGING FROM THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT TO
FURTHER EXPAND OUR TALENT
ACQUISITION EACH. SIZEABLE
NUMBER OF OUR RETAIL EMPLOYEE
IS. I'M FROM THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITY WHERE EACH OF OUR
STORES ARE BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US. AT THAT OUR
HOSPITALITY. COMMUNITIES THAT
WE SERVE. JUST YESTERDAY WE
LAUNCHED A JACKET PREPARATION
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND JOB
FAIR PROGRAMS IN PART WITH THE
LOS ANGELES BROTHERHOOD CRUSADE
A FIFTY YEAR OLD ORGANIZATION
WITH A VISION OF IMPROVING THE
LACK AND- THE FLOW INCOME
UNDERSERVED UNDER REPRESENTED
AND DISENFRANCHISED THE VISUALS
IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES. THE ALL
DAY EVENT WAS HELD AT MAD MEN'S
HEADQUARTERS IN CULVER CITY AN
ATTEMPT EDUCATION ON THE
HISTORY OF BEST THE DIFFERENT
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES IN THE
CANNABIS SPACE. FOR SUPPLY
CHAIN A RESUME AND INTERVIEW
SKILLS BUILDING WORKSHOP. AND A
QUESTION ANSWER PANEL
CONVERSATION WITH MANAGEMENT
EXECUTIVES. DURING WITH
BROTHERHOOD CRUSADE LOUD MAD
MEN TO REACH OUT TO THE
COMMUNITY AND HELP PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES TO WORK IN THE
MERGING CANNABIS INDUSTRY. IN
OCTOBER. CULTIVATED A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP IN
MASSACHUSETTS WITH THE
MASSACHUSETTS ASSOCIATION OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES
MASSACHUSETTS STATE WERE MADE
OF CHINA TYLER ROXBURY
COMMUNITY CALLED GREATER BOSTON
LEGAL SERVICES THE URBAN LEAGUE
AND THE STATE MEDICAL MARIJUANA
DISPENSARY ASSOCIATION TOGETHER
WE CREATED A WORK FORCE
CONTINUING PROGRAM WHERE A
COHORT OF INDIVIDUAL IMPACTED
BY THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
CAN ENROLL IN A CANNABIS
CERTIFICATION COURSE AT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. YOUR RECORD
EXPUNGED A RE CLASSIFIED AND
THEN BE PLACED INTO A PAID
INTERNSHIP WITH DIFFERENT
CANNABIS COMPANIES LIKE MAD MEN
ALL TO ENSURE THAT NEW CANNABIS
INDUSTRY FLEX THE DIVERSITY OF
MASSACHUSETTS AND BOUGHT
COMMUNITIES WE WOULD WELCOME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO IMPLEMENT
SIMILAR. IN CALIFORNIA. HAVING
TO OUR AFTER BROWN COMMUNITY
REINVESTMENT CORPORATE SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND SOCIAL
EQUITY WE'RE BUILDING MADMEN
NEXT. DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
DESIGNED TO SUPPORT THE
TRAINING OF SOCIAL EQUITY
ENTREPRENEURS IN THE INDUSTRY.
I'VE WRITTEN A TEN WEEK SOCIAL
EQUITY BUSINESS OWNERSHIP
CORPUS THAT IS FREE. AS ASIAN
THAT WANTS TO ADOPT IT AND
WE'RE PACKAGING OUR PROPRIETARY
MAD MEN RETAIL LEARNING
MANAGEMENT SOFTWARE AND SHARING
IT WITH CITIES REGULATORS AND
NONPROFIT PARTNERS. THE GOAL IS
TO ENTER HER PARTNERS TO THE
MANY FACETS OF THE INDUSTRY
SHOW THEM HOW TO TAKE A
CANNABIS BUSINESS SUCCESSFUL
AND PROFITABLE IN THIS HIGHLY
REGULATED ONEROUS SPACE. MAD
MEN REGULARLY PARTNER WITH
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS IN THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE. FOR PRIDE
MONTH IN OUR CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
WE DEDICATED A PORTION OF SALES
TO A QUALITY CALIFORNIA. ALSO
WORK WITH LOCAL CHARITIES IN
VARIOUS CITIES IN WHICH OPERATE
LIKE RISING SUN AND REFILL
CALIFORNIA ONE ARCHIVES
FOUNDATION IN WEST HOLLYWOOD
CALIFORNIA. BILLS IN CULVER
CITY CA. SOCIAL EQUITY
ENTREPRENEURSHIP. I ALREADY
FROM BATMAN GENERALLY WHEN
DISCUSSING SOCIAL. THE SPACE
THERE MUST BE A FOCUS ON CHIP
AND- ACTED BY THE WAR ON DRUGS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE OWNERS IN
THIS CANNABIS ECONOMY. THAT IS
WHY WE'VE PARTNERED WITH SOCIAL
EQUITY ENTREPRENEURS IN THREE
CITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO
AID THEM IN MY OWN RETAIL
OPERATIONS AND TO GIVE THEM. TO
CAPITAL. WE PRIDE OURSELVES IN
THE PROGRAMS I JUST DESCRIBED
AND WE APPRECIATE. LATER AND
REGULATORY EIGHT THESE TO
STRENGTHEN THE GOAL LICENSE
CANNABIS MARKET AND LIMIT THE
MARKET. ENSURING A WELL
REGULATED LOT PLAYING FIELD FOR
CANNABIS OPERATORS WILL ENSURE
THAT COMPANIES LIKE MAD MEN CAN
CONTINUE TO DEVELOP AND. RAM
STATION TODAY THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY AND
FOR PROVIDING A VENUE TO THIS
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY. THAT WAS.
IN FOR. THE PROGRAMS THAT
YOU'VE MISSED THE IN IN THE- IF
YOUR SERVER INTELLIGENT VERY
NICE THING. AB. THANK YOU HELLO
IN SENATOR MITCHELL'S VERY NICE
TO YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS AMY
JENKINS I'M THE SENIOR POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CAL OF THIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OR C. C.
I. A. IN HERE. THEN TODAY I'M
WE GET REGRET SHE CANNOT BE OR
SHE HAS THE BILL AND YOU DO NOT
WANT HER HERE. I'M. SO TO SEE
IF YOU. I MEAN NOT FORTUNATELY
NOT SO CCA'S MEMBERSHIP
INCLUDES OVER FIVE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES REPRESENTING. SIX
HUNDRED SEVENTY BRANDS AND
APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES. DOESN'T RETAIN SEES
THAT'S BEEN TO UNITE THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
BY ENHANCING PUBLIC AND
CONSUMER SAFETY TING LEGACY
BUSINESSES PROMOTING
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND ENCOURAGES
INVESTMENTS AND INNOVATION. WE
ARE VERY PROUD OF THE WORK WE
HAVE ACCOMPLISHED MUCH OF WHICH
HAS BEEN DONE IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE LEGISLATURE. UNLESS
CALIFORNIA'S CANNABIS INDUSTRY
CAN. SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES AND
MORE WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
PROMOTE A THRIVING THE CANNABIS
MARKET PLACE. AUSTIN TWENTY
SIXTEEN WITH 57% OF THE VOTE
PROP SIXTY FOUR LEGALIZED THE
USE OF CANNABIS AND FINANCE FOR
ADULTS. IT ALSO ENDED THE
DECADES LONG HELD WERE ON DRUGS
AND MADE IT MEANT TO
ESTABLISHING A COMPREHENSIVE
LEGAL. MARKET. RESPONSE WHEN
YOU COMPANIES EXPAND STAFF AND
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PREPARATION
TRANSITION OF CUSTOMERS TO THE
REGULATED MARKET. IF THE
PROMISE OF PROP SIXTY. NOT BEEN
FULLY REAL THE VAST MAJORITY OF
LEGAL BUSINESS. EMILY ST FORD
AND TWENTY SIXTH IN
UNANTICIPATED COMPLICATIONS ARE
NOW. LEGAL CANNABIS BUSINESSES
AND THREATENING THEIR ABILITY
TO THRIVE SIMPLY STATION TOOK
FULL EFFECT ALMOST TWO YEARS
AGO WE HAVE CONSISTENTLY SEEN
SLOWER THAN EXPECTED GROWTH
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MARKET
PLACE LIKE MANY NEW LEADS LEGAL
MARKETS REPEATEDLY MISSING
REGULATORS AND ANALYSTS
PROJECTIONS. MEANWHILE THE
ILLICIT MARKET CONTINUES TO
GROW. CENTRAL TO PROP SIXTY
FOUR IS THE CONCEPT CONTROL
WHICH EMPOWERS LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO PERMIT OR
BANNED COMMERCIAL CANNABIS.
VOTERS ON WHERE THESE
BUSINESSES MAY BE LOCATED WELL
IT WAS EXPECTED TIME WOULD BE
NEEDED FOR CITIES AND COUNTIES.
CANNABIS ORDINANCE SAYS
CURRENTLY LESS THAN 40% OF
CALIFORNIA'S FOUR HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY TWO IS AND FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES ARE ALLOWING CAREER
CANNABIS ARE. IN THERE. OF THIS
FOR OF THIS 40% MANY ARE
LIMITED TO ONLY CERTAIN
BUSINESSES. BY CHANGE IN FACT
ONLY ABOUT ONE IN FOUR
JURISDICTIONS ALLOW FOR RETAIL
STORE. RESULT VOTERS LACK
ACCESS TO THE LEAVE OUT OF THIS
MARKET PLACE STATEWIDE IT MEANT
AS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT DO
DECIDE TO PERMIT COMMERCIAL
CANNABIS ACT THESE IMPOSE
UNTENABLE RESTRICTIONS ON THOSE
BUSINESSES OR GREATLY LIMIT
AVAILABLE REAL ESTATE FOR
CANNABIS BUSINESSES TO A STOP.
PLEASE THERE ARE ALSO
SIGNIFICANT TAX BURDEN BIRD
WITH THE COMBINATION OF STATE
THE BEST TAXES THE IMPOSITION
OF LOCAL TAXES OF THAT'S WERE
SET ON STATE OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN CHOOSE TO TAX
THIS BUSINESSES AS MUCH AS THEY
WANT AND THEY DO. AS A RESULT
TAXES ON PRODUCTS CAN CONFOUND
COMPOUND TO UPWARDS OF 50% IN
SOME JURISDICTIONS. THIS
TRANSLATES TO A MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS REMAINING
IN THE ILLICIT MARKET
UNDERCUTTING THE PRICES OF THE
REGULAR MARKET AND CHANGING
ENDANGERING CONSUMER AND WORKER
SAFETY. ALLOWING BUSINESSES TO
OPERATE WITHOUT REGULATIONS
TAXES TESTING OR ACCOUNTABILITY
WELL DELETED COME IT'S PAY AS
MUCH AS 50% IN TAXES PLUS
ONEROUS. COMPLIANCE FEES MAKES
IT IMPOSSIBLE. THIS IS TO
COMPETE THE RESULT IS THAT WE
CONTINUE TO PUSH MORE CUSTOMERS
INTO THE ILLICIT GET WE CAN
ALSO ASSUME THAT A LISTEN
OPERATORS DO NOT MAINTAIN WORK.
INSURANCE PAM PLYMOUTH TAX WERE
PROVIDE HEALTH RETIREMENT AND
OTHER BENEFITS THUS DENYING
WORKERS THE PAY AND BENEFITS
AFFORDED TO EMPLOYEES WORKING
AND. MOREOVER THESE OPERATIONS
OFTEN MISCLASSIFIED. AS A
RESULT ARE LIKELY UNDERPAYING
WORK FOR THEIR LABOR. ACCORDING
TO A REPORT BY AR FEW AND BDS
X. 80% OF THE CANNABIS MARKET
AND CALIFORNIA REMAINS. THE
SAME REPORT FOUND. LEGAL MARKET
POSTED REVENUES OF TWO POINT
FIVE BILLION LAST YEAR THE
MARKET SIZE UP TECH AS GROWING
TO EIGHT SEVEN BILLION. EVEN
WITH ALL THESE DIFFICULTIES AND
WHILE THE ILLICIT MARKET
CONTINUED POSE A SIGNIFICANT
SHALL. TO THE REGULATED
INDUSTRY STILL REMAIN HOPE
THESE CHALLENGES OBSTACLES ARE
SHORT TERM APPROPRIATE AND FOR
TEN BY REGULATORS. EFFORTS BY
ESSENCE BUSINESSES TO PROVIDE.
HIGH QUALITY ULTIMATELY DRIVE
LONG TERM GROWTH FOR THE
REGULATED AND THREE. IN FACT
MANY COMPANIES ARE MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS NOW ME INDUSTRY A
LACK OF THAT'S OFTEN LEADS TO
EMPLOY A ROLL BACKS
UNFORTUNATELY THIS HAS BEEN
INCREASINGLY NECESSARY.
INDUSTRY AS THEY'RE TRYING TO
STOP THE LEGAL MARKET. THE
BUSINESS DAILY PUBLISHED AN
ARTICLE IN OF FOR SIX ABOUT THE
GROWING TREND OF EMPLOYEE
LAYOFFS SINCE OCTOBER. IS
DECISIONS ARE FALL THEY
ELIMINATE THE IMPERATIVE NEED
TO INCENTIVIZE ILLICIT
OPERATORS AND THEIR CUSTOMERS
TO JOIN THE REGULATED MARKET.
IT IS TIME TO CREATE A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD FOR BUSINESSES
THAT INVESTED IN THE PROMISE OF
LEGALIZATION AND XIN. ON TOP OF
THESE FINANCIAL BURDENS
CANNABIS OPERATORS ARE ALSO AT
A DISADVANTAGE DUE TO THE LACK
OF BANKING ACCESS THIS MAKES
COMMON BUSINESS PRACTICES SUCH
AS PROCESSING PAYROLL AND
PAYROLL TAXES UNNECESSARILY
COMPLICATED. AND I WANT TO
THANK BOTH SENATE ONE SHERMAN
HELL FOR SUPPORTING A LOT OF
THE BANKING REFORM EFFORTS THAT
WE CONTINUE TO TRY TO PURSUE IN
THE LEGISLATURE. THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY REMAINS COMMITTED TO
REDUCING BARRIERS. PUTTING
BARRIERS TO CALM AND PROMOTING
FAIR EQUITABLE THRIVING AS A
THRIVING INDUSTRY. TOWARDS TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
ADVANCE POLICIES THAT PROMOTE
SOCIAL ACT AND THE WORK FORCE.
MANY LOCUSTS JUST LEARN. MANY
LOCAL TERRACE DIGS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FROM THE STATE HAVE
ALREADY BEGUN. THING OUT EQUITY
PROGRAMS TO- THAT THOSE MOST OF
DEAD BY THE WAR ON DRUGS
BENEFIT FROM THE NEW
OPPORTUNITIES THE LEGAL
INDUSTRY. AT THE SAME TIME WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO OPPOSE
POLICIES THAT IMPOSE NEW
REGULATORY BURDENS ON OUR
INDUSTRY OR TREE CAM APPLICANTS
AND BUSINESSES DIFFERENT OTHER
INDUSTRIES LICENSED BY THE
STATE. SUCH POLICIES RUN
COUNTER TO CALIFORNIA'S GOAL OF
DE STIGMATIZE. IN THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY WHICH IS ALREADY MADE
NUMEROUS CONCESSIONS IN AN
EFFORT TO BE LIGHT AND
REGULATED LIKE ANY OTHER
BUSINESS. IN CLOSING THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY LOOKS FORWARD
TO THE CONTINUED. WE HAVE. AS
WELL AS WITH LABOR PATIENT
SIMMER GROUPS TO FORTIFY THE
REGULATED MARKET WITH YOUR HELP
WE CAN AND WILL ELIMINATE THE
ILLICIT MARK. PROTECTED GOOD
PAYING JOBS REDUCE TAXES TECH
CAN SEE HEALTH AND SAFETY AGAIN
I THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING CCH
TESTIFIED. I AM HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THAT THAN THAT. IT WAS
VERY INTERESTING IN FACT. WHICH
IS THE ONE THAT I HAVE IT OVER.
FOLLOW FOR A LITTLE WHILE WITH
THANK YOU HOW ARE YOU THANK.
SENATE MITCHELL FOR HAVING
YESTERDAY HONOR TO BE HERE IT'S
A GREAT TOPIC AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING HEARING IN THE FIRST
PL. RESIDENTS IN BEING AN
SPENDING THE TIME WITH. PLACE I
GET MY NAME ERIC SKLAR I'M THIS
FOUNDER AND CEO OF THROUGH THE
RIVER ECKLEY ANYBODY CAMPUS
COMPANY LOCATED IN NAPA VALLEY.
I'M ALSO REQUIRED TO MENTION
ANOTHER HAD I WHERE I'M
PRESENTLY THE PRESS. GAME
COMMISSION. AND MY COUNSEL ON
THE CAN AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
VOTE ON THE RULES COMMITTEE CAN
FOR MANY YEARS AGO. THE CARD
DAYS MISSION I'M HERE AS A
PRIVATE CITIZEN IN HERE ON
BEHALF OF MY COMPANY NOT
REPRESENTATION IN COMMISSION.
MY COMPANY IS A VERTICALLY
INTEGRATED CANNABIS COMPANY
THAT MEANS WE DO EVERYTHING
FROM CULTIVATION. THROUGH
CREATING BRANDS THAT END UP ON
A IN IN CONSUMERS HOUSES AND
ON. AND IN THEIR HANDS I'M WE
DO EVERYTHING BETWEEN INCLUDING
MANUFACTURING DISTRIBUTION. AND
WE'RE ACTUALLY JUST A DELIVERY
SERVICE FOR THE MOST OF THE
NORTH BAY SAN FRANCISCO UNDER
THE EASE BANNER. THE BIG
DELIVERY COMPANY WE DELIVER TO
MARIN. NAPA SOLANO COUNTIES. WE
WANT TO. DO THIS OFTEN WHETHER
IT'S ON THIS MY LAKE ISSUES OR
IN CANADA- I HAVE SOME TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT. OR SOMETHING
THAT I MET YOU KNOW ASKING FOR-
I AMY AND MORE. GOOD JOB OF
COVERING THE TOPICS I'M
ACTUALLY HERE TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT FIRST. BUT WITH WORKING.
RIGHT AS A- WONDERFUL THING. SO
OUR COMPANY LIKE. THAT WHICH-
IS GREATER WITH MORGAN. CAM
WITH THE COMPANY'S DOING
TERRIFIC WORK THEY'RE DOING WE
ARE A. LIKE EVERYBODY EVERY
RATE REGULATED CANNABIS
COMPANY. L. P. A.'S. THE UFCW
WITH THE TEAMSTERS THE UFCW FOR
OUR DELIVERY SERVICE AND THE
TEAMSTERS FOR CULTIVATION SITES
WE JUST HAD OUR- BARGAINING AT
THE GROCERY. TUESDAY WITH THE
U. S. E. W. WELL. WE ARE WE
THINK THAT THAT'S THE ALL
BUSINESS SHOULD OPERATE THAT
WAY. BECAUSE REQUIRED AND
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IN IT ALL OF
OUR EMPLOYEES ARE DONE TO
EMPLOYEES AND WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT- THAT IT IS RIGHT TO GET
A- HOT NOT PAYING THE FARE
COMPLAIN THE TAXES AND BENEFITS
THAT THAT THE KING WORKERS.
SUBJECT AT TO MISSING- AND SO
EVEN IF. THE W. TO LAW THE
STATE WE WOULD BE DOING THAT.
BUT WE THINK IT'S A REALLY GOOD
RULE FOR OUR INDUSTRY. FOR ALL
THE MYSTERIES AND WE SUPPORT
ANY EFFORT TO MAKE IT. WILL
PLAYING FIELD. THE SAME GOES
FOR THE WORK WITH WHAT WITH THE
UNIT. IS MY ALL OUT. BUSINESSES
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO SIGN- DAYS
WHEN THERE'S CERTAIN SIDE. WE
FOUND OUR FIRST WOMAN OUR FIRST
COMPANY BECAME TED TWENTY
EMPLOYEES WHICH IS WHAT
REQUIRED. BUT OUR SECOND
COMPARE CULTIVATION COMPANY WE
SIGNED WITH THE TEAMSTERS
BEFORE THAT. ON BECAUSE WE
THINK IT'S THE RIGHT.
FUNDAMENTALLY WE NEED TO HAVE A
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD. I'M IT'S
NOT LEVEL NOW UNDERSTANDABLE
IT'S AN. BIG THING TO PASS PROP
SIXTY FOUR IN TO DO THAT WITH
THERE HAD TO BE THINGS IN THAT
WERE NEXT. TO PROBABLY GET A
PASS. ON STATE MAYBE MORE.
WE'RE CENTRAL ANY REALLY
TALKED. AT LENGTH IN WELL
ABOUT. THE ISSUE OF LOCAL
CONTROL THE LITTLE IT IS THE
BIGGEST THREAT NOW. EXPERIMENT
CANNABIS BUT IS TO WORKERS
THOSE WORKERS AREN'T PART OF A
UNION THERE ARE THAT
OPPORTUNITY THEY DON'T GET
BENEFITS THEY'RE BY DEFINITION
GIG WORKERS THEY DON'T HAVE
WITH WHOLE WITHHOLDINGS TAKEN
CARE OF FOR THEM. A REAL
DISADVANTAGE JUST ON THAT
FINANCIAL PERSPECTIVE BUT.
SAFETY I'M WORKING THOSE
ILLEGAL BUSINESSES ARE OVERALL
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IS TO
HANDLE ILLEGAL MARKET THAT'S
WHAT AND THE PROBLEM IS ABOUT
HAVE IT ALL THE REGULATED. THAN
THAT WE OUGHT TO HAVE A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD WHERE CANNABIS
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE A HARDER
TIME. YES WHEN I. WE SHOULD
HAVE BURDENS PUT ON US THAT ON
ON OTHER BUSINESSES THAT ARE
THAT ARE LEGAL AND LEGITIMATE
AS WELL. AND THAT WILL HELP THE
STIGMA ATTACHED TO STIGMATIZE
INDUSTRY AS WE TALK ABOUT IN
SOME OF THE EARLIER COMMENTS
TODAY. SO IMPORTANT. I DO THINK
IS RUSHING TO THE PRESENTATION
FROM NORMAL. WE HAVE A DELIVERY
BUSINESS WE HAVE WE'VE CREATED
I THINK SIXTY. JOBS IN LAKE
COUNTY. I'M THE POOL WANTED TO
POOREST COUNTY IN THE STATE IN
THE LAST SEVENTEEN MONTHS.
THOSE PEOPLE ARE DRIVERS
DELIVERING CANNABIS PRODUCTS
SOME. AN APPROPRIATE TREATMENT
FOR THOSE IN AND TO BE CVD WERE
HAS NO IMPACT ON THEIR DRIVING
ABILITY BECAUSE OF THE LACK
RESEARCH AND BECAUSE OF CURRENT
LAW WE HAVE TO SEVEN ZERO EIGHT
ZERO TOLERANCE POLICY ON.
CANNABIS USE I CAN'T. TWENTY SO
IT'S SOMETHING WE NEED TO SOLVE
I THINK ANYBODY IS TO BLAME FOR
ITS REALITY THERE'S BEEN SO
LITTLE RESEARCH PARTLY BECAUSE
OF FEDERAL LAW MAKE. SO HARD TO
FUND RESEARCH BUT THE STATE
COULD REALLY BE A LEADER IN
ADAM. ANY PRE ATION. HIS YOU
KNOW HAPPENING AT THE THC IN
YOUR BLOOD STREAM. BECAUSE IT
REALLY IS A CHALLENGES WAS SO
WELL DESCRIBED EARLIER SO WE
YOU KNOW WE THANK YOU FOR THE
WORK YOU'RE DOING THIS TO
CONTINUALLY IMPROVE. THE AFTER.
FOR THIS INDUSTRY TO HELP BRING
IT LIST LEGITIMIZATION AND. WE
CAN AND THE ILLEGAL MARKET.
WHICH IS BETTER FOR. FROM
VITAMINS. BETTER FOR.
CALIFORNIA SO AGAIN THANK YOU
AND HAPPY THREE WHICH IS THE
MAKERS WERE IN ENOUGH OF START
WITH YOU TO DO. DO YOU SEE. THE
FUTURE WE HAVE OF THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY IF YOU SEE IT. THE TAX
ISSUE AND THE. CERTAINLY THOSE
THAT ARE UP I'D OF THE LEGAL
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE HAVE TODAY
YOU HAD OUT WOULD YOU SEE IT
WHEN YOU SEE IT HE IS A SOLVING
THESE PROBLEMS AND THIS IS IN
IN ON THE SITUATION- BUT WELL I
HOPE. SO I. AM NOT A STRATEGY
ROOM BUT I. PEOPLE DEEPLY CAN.
IS LATER I KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITTED TO THE SUCCESS OF
THIS EXPERIMENT. AND THE
INDUSTRY IS I THINK THE PEOPLE.
WANT TO SEE THE SIXTY. SO I'M
UP TO. WE PROBLEMS BUT HE THERE
ARE PROBLEMS AND- AND WE NEED
TO WALL WORK TOGETHER TO FIX
THEM IF IS. EXCEED BECAUSE
THERE'S STILL A POSSIBILITY.
GIVEN THAT YOU KNOW THE RATIO
OF ILLEGAL ILLEGAL MARKET.
THERE'S STILL THE POSSIBILITY
THAT THIS EXPERIMENT FAILED.
AND WE GO BACK TO. YOU KNOW
ENTIRELY ILLEGAL MARKET NOW THE
DISASTER. SO MANY REASONS. SO
WHETHER ON. ON LOCAL ACCESS IS
CRITICAL- AS LONG AS THERE'S
ONLY FOUR HUNDRED SO
DISPENSARIES IN THE STATE OF.
THE FORTY MILLION PEOPLE.
PEOPLE GONNA GO DEAL. BECAUSE
THE DOING FOREVER AND THE BAY
PRICES WERE SAYING IS ALL ABOUT
THAT. INJURY THAT HAPPENS WHEN
THERE'S AN ILLEGAL MARKET. IN A
WAY THAT IT WILL NOT HAPPEN IN
A REGULATED MARKET ALL OF OUR-
TEST TO A FARE THEE WELL. WHICH
IS GREAT WE WANT. MORE SAFE. SO
I THINK THAT THINGS LIKE LOCAL
ACCESS. DOING SOMETHING TO. IT
DEVICE WITH A CARROT AND STICK
MAYBE LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO.
DOING THEIR. JOB AND YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU SLICE TO ALLOW THESE
LEGITIMATE BUSINESS WEEK.
EITHER ACTION OF. BEING ALONE
LIMITED PROHIBITION. THIS
EXAMPLE OF THE STATE. KAMALA
CARROTS ARIVED THERE IS TAX
MONEY AVAILABLE. TO ENCOURAGE
LOCAL RACES I WOULD SAY THAT'S
NUMBER ONE. IS GETTING MORE
LEGAL BUSINESS. AND ACROSS THE
STATE IN THIS IS THAT'S
INTRODUCED A YEAR IN THE
DELIVERY BUSINESSES WELL OF.
THE IN THIS COSTA MY- IGNORANCE
OF THE- TOPIC BUT IF I RECALL.
THERE'S A BIG QUESTION NOW
WHETHER YOU CAN DELIVER IN.
HAVE AID THAT DECISION TO HAVE
A RETAIL ESTABLISHMENT AND I
BELIEVE THAT IN THE FORTUNE OUR
HOUSE THAT IS IN THE COURSE OF
IT STANDS AS THE STATE IS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS HAD THAT
I'M SURE THAT THE BCC AND THE-
AND THE REGULATIONS. IF SINCE
LIVE RECON. BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BRING LEGAL LICENSE
PRODUCT TO ADULTS ARE YOU MAY
DELIVER ANYWHERE IN THE STATE
FROM YOUR LOCATION WHATEVER
LOCALITY AND SO FOR INSTANCE
AND THEY CAN. MAKE THEIR LACK.
LIVING TO SEVEN COUNTIES FROM
THAT ONE DEEP. NOT VERY
EFFICIENT WE MUCH RATHER HAVE
ONE IN SAUSALITO AND ONE IN YOU
KNOW IN IN VACAVILLE BUT FOR
NOW WE'RE DOING THAT. IT'S COLD
OUTSIDE IN THE YOU CAN LIVE
RESIDENT. BILLY A GROUP OF
SEASONAL AND LEGAL CITIES HAVE
SUED THE STATE. SITE IN POLICY
IN THAT CASE THE PROCESS. OKAY
THANK YOU. SO UP. TO THE ISSUE
IT TO. THE TO THE THAT I KNOW
AND THIS. WAS TALKING. ABOUT DO
YOU ARE THERE OTHERS THAT. MR
WE MAY HAVE MISSED IN THEIR- TO
BE HELPFUL I THINK SHE REALLY
CARED AT HOLISTICALLY OF COURSE
THERE IS THE TENSION BETWEEN
FEDERAL PROHIBITION AND WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN STATES I THINK
WE'RE SEEING A LOT OF. ONLY
MORE SO THAN WE'VE EVER SEEN OR
ESPECIALLY IN TERMS OF AND THE
SAFE BANKING ACT AND DISCUSSION
AROUND. NOTE THE SCHEDULE
PLAYING FIRST SAYS JUST
ACKNOWLEDGING STATES THAT HAVE
LEGAL MARIJUANA Là AS AN
CONSIDERING AT THE SCHEDULING
IN THOSE STATES THROUGH THE
STATE ACT OR HAVE SOCIAL EQUITY
SHOULD BE A LEVEL. I'M AT AS WE
CONTINUE TO SEE A SEA CHANGE
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES AND
MORE STATES COMING ON LINE IT
ALSO HELPS. BEING OF FOLKS AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL UNTIL. YOU
KNOW THE CONTEMPORARY TIMES OF
WE'RE SEEING IN CALIFORNIA BUT
I THINK SHE APPROPRIATELY
CAPTURED AT THING THERE
DEFINITELY IS A TENSION BETWEEN
THE ILLICIT MARKET AND A LEGAL
ONE AND I THINK. IT'S A REAL
CHALLENGE ESPECIALLY. THE HARMS
THAT THE WAR ON DRUGS HAS HAD
ON COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
BEING ABLE TO ENSURE THAT THE
FOLKS WHO WANT TO MOVE INTO THE
REGULATED INDUSTRY DO NOT HAVE
BARRIERS TO DO SELL. DIFFERENT
KINDS PROPOSED LEGISLATION THAT
HAVE. REDUCED FEE. OR FEEL THE
FIRST FOR PAUL TO COME INTO THE
LEGAL REGULATED MARKET
IMPORTANT. ALL AND THAT IS ALSO
WHY MADMEN PUTS. MAD MEN NEXT.
PROVIDING DIFFERENT KINDS OF
CORRECT I'M IN TRAINING ABOUT
HOW TO BE SICK THIS MARKET
ESPECIALLY AS SOCIAL EQUITY
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE THE
ONLY WAY THAT. WELL AS IF THEY
ARE NOT COMPETING AGAINST
ELLISON. OTHER THING I WOULD
ADD TO THAT IS IT FOR CONSUMERS
TO DIFFERENTIATE BUT ILLICIT
OPERATORS AND LEGAL REGULATED
OPERATORS. THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES THEY LOOK VERY SIMILAR-
AND SELL. DECISION AROUND AN
EMBLEM PROGRAM OR JUST MORE
EDUCATION TO CONSUMERS ABOUT
HOW TO CHECK FOR WHAT IS
POPULATED VERSUS NOT I THINK
IT'S STILL NEEDED. HELP MAY MAY
I DID TELL YOU KNOW A GOOD DEAL
OF THE LEGAL COULD PRODUCTION
OUR STATE ACTUALLY GOES OUT OF
STATE TO AND SO THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT THE STATE OVER
OREGON PASSED A LAW THAT ALLOWS
INTERSTATE SHIPPING BETWEEN TWO
TO SEE. THE LIGHTS CAM IF
THEY'RE CONTIGUOUS THERE'S A
MOVIE UNDER WAY TO LOOK AT A
FEDERAL KIND OF EITHER A
COOPERATIVE AGREEMENT. BUT ALSO
GET THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ALLOW SHIPPING ACROSS STATE
LINES THAT WOULD GO A LONG WAY
ALSO. BECAUSE YOU CAN SHIP IT
OUT OF STATE LEGALLY THEN WILL
BE MORE INCENTIVE FOR THESE
ILLEGAL ROLLERS TO GET IT. CAN
TODAY SHIP FROM CANNOT YOU CAN
ACHIEVE APPROXIMATELY I DON'T
THINK THAT WOULD BE YEP FEDERAL
BUT BUT THEORETICALLY IF I IF
YOU RADICALLY IF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATURE PASSED THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED A BILL. THAT
THAT WE WILL. BE ACROSS THE
STATE LINE CONTINUOUS SAY TO
ALLOW WASHINGTON OREGON. NEVADA
ALL TO SHIP AMONG THEMSELVES
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH IT BUT- IN THE
END. THERE YOU'RE NOT CROSSING
OF US AT THE US BORDER YOU'RE
CROSSING STATE FOR FROM ONE
STATE TO ANOTHER. TO THE SOME
OF THE SOME. EL PASO SIMILAR
LOT ORGANS. WE COULD START
SHIPPING ACROSS A LEDGE WOULD
BE GREAT FOR CALIFORNIA ECONOMY
BECAUSE- JUST LIKE EVERY OTHER
CROP CALIFORNIA'S BACK. GROWING
AT THE MOST DAYS OUR WEATHER IS
YOUR PERFECT GOING INTO THIS. I
THINK WE CAN BE A LEADER IN
CANADA'S PRESSURE CROSSING.
ONCE WE CAN START. PROCESSING
PLANT. AND I THINK THAT WILL
HELP. YOU SEE NOT ILLEGAL
GROWTH GROW GROWING THAT'S
GOING ON. IN HIS MID MEN STILL.
CALIFORNIA ARE YOU STILL IN.
MORE IN CALIFORNIA AND SHE THE
GROWTH POTENTIAL THERE ARE YOU
OPTIMISTIC WE'RE INCREDIBLY
OPTIMISTIC CALIFORNIA'S WHERE
WE BUILT THIS IS WHERE WE WANT
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE A DEEP
ROOTS. CAN YOU IT TO EXPAND OUR
MARKET SO WHAT WE'RE GOING
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF APPLYING
FOR DIFFERENT LICENSES IN
CITIES THAT ARE COMING ONLINE
AND PLOWING WHETHER IT IS A
RETAIL BUSINESS OR EVEN
DELIVERY DEPOT BECAUSE WE ALSO
DO DELIVERY AT THE COMPANY. AND
WILL ALWAYS HAVE CALIFORNIA'S
PART OF OUR PORTFOLIO THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO US. THANK
YOU. COM YOUR PRECIADO SIXTY
MINUTES THAT A PIECE FULL
SUNDAYS AGO- AND I WAS STRUCK
BY THIS NOTION IN CALIFORNIA IS
PUT IS NOT OVER PRODUCING. AND
THE AND THE FOCUSED ON THE
DESERT BE ABLE TO. YOU KNOW HOW.
THE SOLUTION THERE DO WE DO WE
SLOW DOWN PRODUCTION. ON THE
OTHER CHALLENGES YOU EXPERIENCE
WITH I MEAN THINK ABOUT OUR.
HISTORIC AG. BUSINESS FOCUSES
BEEN TO FEED THE WORLD OUR IT'S
A BIT OF A TRANSITION. SO HOW
DOES THE INDUSTRY JEFF OVER
SOMEONE HOW TO SO. ALL CITY
DEMAND WELL SO FIRST OF ALL AT
THE END HELLO SIXTY MINUTES I
THINK THEY GOT IT WRONG TO
AGREE. WASTE AND IS TRYING TO.
IN THE LEGAL MARKET I'M TO MY
SURPRISE AND ENJOY AS AS A
CANNABIS GROW OUR PRICES
WITHOUT PRICES WERE GONNA
STEADILY DECLINED OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS THEY HAVE NOT THAT
THE SAME POINT LAST YEAR- A
POUND OF SUN GROWN CANNABIS
FLOWER FROM LAKE COUNTY WERE WE
GROW IS GOING FOR ABOUT NINE
FIFTY DOLLARS IT'S GOING FOR
TWO ELEVEN. AND THIS YEAR SO
WITH THAT IN THE LEGAL MARKET
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH SUPPLY AND
THEY'RE IN AS A SUPPLY GRIST.
OKAY TO BE MORE COMPETITION IS
GOOD FOR CONSUMERS IF THE PRICE
OF THE PRODUCT COMES DOWN
BECAUSE AND RETAIL PRICES COME
DOWN TO IT REALLY IS ABOUT THE
ILLEGAL SIDE OF IT BECAUSE
THOSE FOLKS NOW CAN'T SELL IT-
AT DISPENSARIES THAT THEY MIGHT
IT USED TO BE ABLE. TO MAKE
BECAUSE BEFORE STE FOR. A
GROWER. PROBABLY YOU KNOW
THROUGH THROUGH SOME. SMOKE AND
MIRRORS COULD GET INTO
SPENCER'S AND NOW THIS IS
VETERANS CANNOT TAKE THAT
CANNABIS. UNLESS IT'S IN THE
TRACKING FREE THEM IN A LICENSE
GROWER IS GONE AND TAG IT WITH
THE RADIO ID. ALL PLAN. SO
THERE'S THIS IMBALANCE IN AGAIN
IS THE BECAUSE OF THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE LEAGUE.
LEGAL MARKET. I'M COULD. COME
THEY SHOULD NOT BE THE. GROW
CANNABIS. CASES IN MAINE WHERE
THEY HAVE TO DO IT IN THE- AND
IT'S INCREDIBLY EXPEND. ENERGY
EFFICIENT HOME WHEN WE- SIGNED
GROWING UP FOR THE WHOLE
COUNTRY SO. IT'S A QUICK TO
PROMISE THAT LACK OF A FEDERAL
SYSTEM TO ALLOW IT IS WITH. TO
GATHER BUT ILLEGAL BUT THERE'S
NOT AN OVERSUPPLY IN STATES
LIKE OREGON THERE'S A THEMATIC.
THEY PASSED A LOT OF TO GO OUT
ACROSS THE STATE HOPEFULLY OVER
SOMETHING INTERESTING WHAT. I
DON'T KNOW BUT SHE IS THERE
HE'LL BUT I DON'T KNOW THAT WE
SEE. MOVEMENT AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL ANYTIME SOON. THERE'S A
POTENTIAL CHANGE IN YOU KNOW
LEADERSHIP IN TWENTY TWENTY I
JUST DON'T KNOW THAT AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL FOR YOU GIVEN THE
COMPOSITION OF CONGRESS AT ALL-
AND SO WILL THE BE ADJUSTMENTS
MADE IF THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN AND
WHAT COULD THEY LOOK LIKE YEAH
YEAH SO AGAIN THERE HAVE HAVING
INTERSTATE REMAIN. SHIPPING
WOULD BE WOULD BE HUGE I DO I
DO I'M A LITTLE MORE OPTIMISTIC
ABOUT THE THINGS HAPPENING
WATCHING I THINK THE
IMPEACHMENT PROCESS HAS BOGGED
DOWN AND WILL FOR AWHILE BUT
THE STICK. THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES THIS SUMMER
PASSED. WITH NIGHT. WELL
DEMOCRAT ALMOST ALL THE
DEMOCRATS. THE BANKING ACT
WHICH IS THE FIRST STEP.
CONNELL. OF IT AS IMPLICIT
OTHERWISE. ON THE POPULATIONS
THAT TO ME EIGHT IN THE SPACE
AS WELL. THE PROGRAMS ARE
IMPORTANT DEEPER MORE SYSTEMIC
IT COMES WITH THE AROUND HOW
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR POOR THEIR
PERCEIVED THOSE WHO BEEN FORMER.
TOUCHED BY THE BILL JUST ASSIST
SO IT'S IMPORTANT WE PUSH THE
EQUITY BUT WE CAN'T YOU KNOW A
SO THAT WILL BE ENOUGH THE WE
HAVE TO GO MUCH DEEPER IN TERMS
OF KIND OF A CULTURE SHIFT
AROUND. GET OUT EXPERIENCE BOTH
COMMUNITIES HALF. PARTNERSHIP
WITH BROTHERHOOD CRUSADE
UNINTENDED THIS PROGRAM WAS
YESTERDAY NO ONE DAY LATE I'M
SORRY. THE BEEN SIMPLE TROUBLE
ARE YOU GOING TO DO IT AGAIN
AND ANOTHER ONE IN JANUARY.
HALF OF THE COHORT THAT WAS
THERE. BROTHER HAD AIDS
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT TRAINING
WILL THEN WILL BRING THEM BACK
AND DO A WHOLE HOST OF
INTERVIEWS AGAIN. SO PLEASE
MAKE SURE IT MIGHT JUST OFFICE
KNOWS THAT BECAUSE WE WANT TO
DEFINITELY PARTNER- SINCE WE
HAVE THE PLEDGE OF REPRESENTING
YOUR COVER CITY HEADQUARTERS
YEAH WHICH I HAVE TO COME SEE I
HAVE A LITTLE. TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN NOW I RECORD WITH. OR
INTERNET SO. FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE WHOEVER WANTS TO
ANSWER YOU KNOW WHAT'S THE
BIGGEST OBSTACLE THAT MAY BE A
RATHER SOFT TISSUE BUT AS AS
WHEN I TRY TO WRAP YOUR HEAD
AROUND THIS YOU KNOW IS THE
LACK OF BANKING IS AT THE
BURKE. REGULATION OR IS IT. 60%
OF LOCAL GOT THAT BASICALLY
AREN'T. STEPPED UP TO THE.
PLATE TO PLAY- WHAT'S THE
BIGGEST. I WOULD I WOULD ARGUE
SENATOR IT'S AS THE THIRD IT'S
IF OF ACCESS TO LEGAL PRODUCT
AND IS THAT IS THAT THEIR WAY
OF AS WE GO. BACK CULTURE IS
THEIR WAY OF. NOT SUPPORTING
THE BALLOT INITIATIVE AND JUST
NOT WANTING TO BE IN THE
BUSINESS IS IT CONSTITUENT
PRESSURE. LET A THIRD ELEMENT
INTO THEIR COMMUNITY WHAT WHAT
WHAT ARE WE HEARING FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IT'S FUNNY THE SICK
AFTER FOR EXAMPLE. THE CITY
MAP- PROP SIXTY FOUR PASSED THE
61% IN. 1045% MORE THAN THE
STATE AVERAGE ON THAT
TELEVISION. CANCEL THAT IS
SEVEN IS PERSPECTIVE ON THIS I
THINK IT'S- VERSION AMONG LOCAL
OF. LOOK IN A MIRROR EVERY
MORNING TEA AKON OUR STATE
SENATOR. THEY DON'T DO ANYTHING
IT MESSES UP THEY ONLY. TO GET
ENOUGH. RIGHT IF THEY DO AND SO
THE RISK ADVERSE THEY DON'T
WANT TO DO ANYTHING. BASS
PLAYER BECAUSE- THANKS AND
THEY'RE AFRAID BECAUSE THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND IT. THEY
HAVEN'T SEEN IT OPERATE IT'S A
NEW THING AND SO I THINK MORE
THAN ANYTHING ELSE YOU'LL FIND
A LOT OF KIMI OPPOSITION WE
WENT THERE HEARING. OFTEN IS
LIKE A PARENTS GROUP IS
CONCERNED ABOUT YOUTH AND
THAT'S REALLY. WAS MAKE SURE
THE KIDS DON'T MESS AROUND HERE
WHY THEY SHOULD NOT BE USING IT
IS BECAUSE IT'S WHETHER RANGER
DEVELOPING. WHICH. REPRESENT OF
THE POLICE ASSOCIATION IS YOURS
IS AS HE ATE. AND I CAN
EDUCATION GROUP. EVERYBODY ELSE
AND WAS SUPPORTED AND THAT AND
THE- COUNCIL MEMBERS WHO BUT
YOU'RE STILL RESISTED. I THINK
THAT'S THE BIGGEST THING. IS IT
AND THEY DON'T HAVE ANY REAL
INCENTIVE. RIGHT THERE THE
PROBLEMS FROM THE ILLEGAL
MARKET DON'T AFFECT THEM- AND
DEATH. AND SO I THINK THAT THEY
NEED TO BE A SET OF. POSITIVE
AND NEGATIVE REWARDS FOR NOT
JOB IN ALLOWING THE VOTERS TO
HAVE WITH THEIR- OTHERWISE WHEN
IS THE BALLOT ISSUE AFTER
BALLOT INITIATIVE WHICH IS A
TERRIBLE WAY TO LEGISLATE. YES.
A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE IN
TERMS OF THE. BIG ROLE YEAH I
WOULD BE THAT IT'S DEFINITELY
ABOUT A LACK OF ACCESS TO IN
DIFFERENT CITIES I THINK.
ANOTHER REASON WHY IS A
CHALLENGE FOR CITIES TO.
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY
DIFFERENT MODELS OUT CALIFORNIA
AND SO FOR THEM TO TAKE IT ON
SEEING THAT SOME CITIES ARE
MIRED IN LAWSUITS THROUGH THE-
LOT COMPETITIVE LICENSING SSE
IS THAT THEY HAVE O CREATE. AT
TIMES AN ENTIRELY NEW
DEPARTMENT AT THE CITY AND
NEEDS TO BE. THEY'RE GOING TO
DO IT FOR. IT'S NOT THE EASIEST
THING TO EMPLOYMENT AS MIGHT BE
VALLEY'S INTO RIGHT NOW SO I
STUDENTS ABOUT THE- PROCESS IN
THE AND HOW. LICENSES HAVE BEEN
SELECTED YES AND I. A HAS DONE
AN AMAZING JOB OF PUTTING
TOGETHER MODEL LEGISLATION THE
ORDINANCES ABOUT WHAT. A CITY
CAN DEAL AND THE MORE EXAM. A
PLUGIN PLAY GOLD STANDARD OF
THIS IS HOW YOU SET IT UP ON
THE BACK. CITIES PERHAPS THAT
CAN. HELP EXPEDITE IT I ALSO
REALLY THINK WE CAN IGNORE. THE
LIMITED ACCESS TO CAPITAL IT IS
REALLY HARD TO BUSINESS UP AND
RUNNING AND TO ENSURE THAT
BUSINESSES ARE SUCCESSFUL
ESPECIALLY IN THE FIRST YEAR OF
OPERATE. IF YOU DON'T HAVE
STATE. BUT ALL IN THERE ARE A
LOT OF FEAR. ACROSS THE BOARD
SURE IF THAT ONE LAST QUESTION
MAY THIRTY OF COURSE THE-
PERCENT OF LOCAL. WHO ARE THE
IS IF YOU CAN THESE ARE THESE
ARE THE I. I THINK BY AND IT
COUNTIES ARE ARE WE FOCUSED ON
CULTIVATION. TEND TO AUTHORIZE
AS MANY DIFFERENT COMMERCIAL
CAMPUS ACTIVITIES I THINK
NUMBERS CLEARLY CITIES OF THE
WORST OFFENDERS WE OF FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO CITIES.
ALL OF OUR OUR OUR RETAIL.
WITHIN THE AS AN WITH ONE AND
FOUR. THE CITY'S ACTUALLY THE
RACING RETALIATING PARTICULAR
PROBLEM AND I DO. IT'S MADE BY
BOTH. BECAUSE I'M IN TERMS OF.
ACCESS IT JUST MAKES ALL. THE
ABILITY TO LICENSED HE'S IN
EVERY COMMUNITY IT'S MUCH
EASIER. ADDRESS THE ILLICIT
MARKET RIGHT WHERE WE SAW
ILLNESS AND WHERE WE HAVE YES
THE VIENEN. AND EIGHTY COUNCIL
WHERE THERE ARE THERE IS. SAFE
COMPLIANCE PRODUCTS YEAH I JUST
WANTED TO SAY TERRIBLY
DIFFICULT ALL THE TIME YEAH
WITH THE WITH THE SUPPLY BOUNCY
SELF. ALLOW YOU KNOW
CULTIVATION THAT'S OKAY WE'RE
GONNA PUT ON THE BALLOT NOW.
THAT THAT'LL HAPPEN HAS
HAPPENED IS REALLY ABOUT THE
RETAIL STORES DEALS GETS FIXED
IF YOU WIND UP FOR THEM. AND IN
TERMS OF. TALK ABOUT THE NUMBER
OF CITIES BUT WE IN MY OWN KIND
OF OFFENSE WHEN I COULD THROUGH
THE NUMBER OF UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES. WHO. LOOK TO THE
COUNTY THEIR GOVERNANCE THE NOT
APPLE FIVE WHILE THERE ARE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES BUT IN
TERMS OF NEIGHBORHOODS AND
COMMUNITIES ARE UNDER. THAT
NUMBER GO SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER.
INTERESTING AND AS WE TALK
ABOUT SOCIAL EQUITY OWNERSHIP
AND PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE TO APPLY WHEN THERE ARE
CITIES. THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
THAT IS A LEE ROLLING OUT THEIR
NUMBER OF LICENSES IT IS A
LIMITED NUMBER OF. THIS SO IF
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AND
UNINCORPORATED AREAS IN LA
COUNTY WERE OPEN UP AND ALLOW
FOR LICENSING OPPORTUNITIES.
THEN ALL OF THOSE FOLKS WHO
DIDN'T MAKE THE FIRST. FOR
EXAMPLE COULD THEN APPLY IN A
NEARBY COMMUNITY. THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE. HERE AT THE MONITOR.
HELPFUL WILL MOVE ON TO THE
THIRD PANEL EMPLOYER
STAKEHOLDERS DRUG TESTING
POLICIES AND FEDERAL COMPLIANCE
ROBERT THREE POLICY ADVOCATE OF
THE CALIFORNIA DRAPER IN RICE
POLICY DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS AT THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS KNOWLEDGES
ASSOCIATION. HELLO NICOLE
WELCOME. THANK YOU FOR A THIS
WILL BE. INFORMATIVE TURN IN A
RECOVERY. I'M WELL THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN HILL PLEASE SO FIRST I
HAVE T SAY THAT I THINK IT'S
EVERYONE ACKNOWLEDGE THERE'S
SOME. AS USUAL EXPRESSED WENT
THROUGH THIS ISSUES RANGE FROM-
EQUITY AND A LONG. WAR THANKS
TO BANKING AND FEDERATION IS
JUST A LOT HERE- AND OF COURSE-
I CAN ONLY SPEAK TO A COUPLE OF
THOSE ISSUES ON BEHALF OF CLICK
ME RIGHT MANY OF THOSE THINGS.
BY MAY HAVE PERSONAL SUBPLOTS
THAT I WISH I COULD FIX. THERE
BEYOND. SO LET'S SEE FIRST THE
EMPLOYEE COMMITTEES GOALS ARE.
ARE REALLY LIMITED HERE RIGHT
AND IT'S- IT'S SAFETY AND THEN
COMPLIANCE WITH BOTH FEDERAL
AND STATE LAW SIMULTANEOUSLY-
AND THAT'S THAT I DON'T THINK
THAT'S PRICES ANYONE- AND- I.
TO AGREE WITH MUCH OF WHAT WAS
SAID BY THE SCIENTIFIC PANEL WE-
THE BIGGEST ISSUE FOR US GOING
THROUGH LOOKING ACROSS SIXTY
FOUR IN AND MOVING TO THE
PRESENT RIGHT. OUR ISSUES THAT
ARE ONGOING WITH- THING RIGHT
SCIENCE ABOUT IT WHEN WE HEARD
AND- IT WAS EXPRESSED MUCH
BETTER THAN THAT I COULD I
DON'T KNOW IF NICOLE CAN DO
BETTER. BUT ON THE ISSUES
IMPROVE TESTING AS YOU ASKED
ABOUT- SALIVA AND TEN THE
BREATH TEST FUTURE. FOR A LOT
OF PROMISE I'M THE ISSUE THAT
WE HAVE IT AND IT'S IMPORTANT
TO US AND TESTING IS THE
PRESENT TENSE WE HAVE A-
PERFECT. RIGHT THE URINE
TESTING IS NOT IDEAL- UNLIKE
ALCOHOL WITH THE FERTILIZER
TEST WE CAN BE PRETTY DECISIVE
SAY. YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GOING
TO YOU KNOW. THAT'S THAT- WE
DON'T HAVE THAT HERE AND UNTIL
WE HAVE A BETTER SYSTEM. THE
FLAG MEETINGS IS VERY IMPORTANT.
SOME WAY TO DO SOME TESTING AS
A SAFETY CONCERN. SO TO GO
THROUGH I WON'T GET INTO THAT
OF ANY RESEARCH I DISCUSSED
EARLIER WELL THAT. SOME OF THE
SIDE EFFECTS OF MARIJUANA CAN
TAKE- INCLUDE- IMPAIRMENT OF
JUDGE A REACTION TIME ISSUES
LIKE THAT RIGHT AGAIN. RESEARCH
ON GOING CAMPUS THAT. WE HOPE
FOR MORE. BUT PUTTING THAT IN
CONTEXT RIGHT WITH THE FEDERAL
PATIENTS IN SOMETHING IT WAS
TOUCHED ON BRIEFLY I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE ON THE SIDE RIGHT.
THERE IS A THE FEDERAL
ENFORCEMENT ISSUE WHICH HOPE
BANKING LAW ME. IN THE CRIMINAL
LAW HAS BEEN GENTLY FORCED- BUT
BIGGEST CONCERN ON THE BUSINESS
SIDE PROUDLY. FEDERAL
CONTRACTING RIGHT AND GRANT
RULES- AROUND A DRUG FREE
WORKPLACE ISN'T AN ACT OF
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT RIGHT.
I'M BECAUSE THE ISSUE FOR ANY
EMPLOYER IN. THE WORKS WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. REGARDLESS
OF WHAT WE DO ON OTHER FRONTS
IF YOU WANT TO CONTINUE WORK
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
YOU'RE VERY CONSTRAINED ON THE
FRONT SO THAT'S- THAT'S A HUGE
ISSUE FOR A LOT OF BIG THIS IN
CALIFORNIA. SO TRYING TO THAT
CAN RESULT IN POSITION RIGHT
THE RESULTING TO DIFFICULT
POSITION WITH PRE EMPLOYMENT
TESTING WHICH IS. YOU KNOW THE
ONE OF THE BIG ISSUES. IS YOU
KNOW WHAT DO YOU DO. THE
THERE'S A REQUEST EARLIER BUT
WHY I'M SORRY CAN A NAY BUT
WHEN ISSUES IS WHAT DO YOU JUST
SKIP. TESTING I'M SOMEONE. HAVE
DONE THAT BECAUSE IT'S THAT YOU
KNOW THEY'VE MADE A CHOICE THAT
THAT'S THE WAY IT LOOKS PRETTY
THEY DON'T WANT TO KNOW. WE
HAVE. BROUGHT COMMUNITY BIG
CONCERNS ABOUT OUR SAFETY
POLICY BEING WELL COULD GET
SOME INFORMATION IT'S IN
PERFECT BUT LET'S JUST NOT GET
IT ALL. YOU KNOW THAT'S A
CONSERVING IT'S IMPORTANT HAVE
THE OPTION GET IT. THE NEXT AS
WELL WHAT IF YOU DO THE TEST
AND SOMEONE COMES UP POSITIVE
FOR ME. AND YOU HIRE THEM
ANYWAY. WELL OBVIOUSLY FEDERAL
ISSUE CONCERNED RIGHT IF YOU
CONTRACT FEDERALLY- AND IF YOU
DON'T CONTRACT BUT REALLY
THERE'S A CONCERN. LIABILITY
THEIR LAWSUITS THAT CAN.
PROVIDE A NEGLIGENT HIRING IF
YOU'RE AWARE. BUT EMPLOYEE
POTENTIALLY AND THAT. LATER
THERE IS AN ACCIDENT. THAT
YOU'RE FACING A LIABILITY OR
EVEN IF YOU. EVENTUALLY ARM.
WRESTLING ALLEGED IN YOUR. THE
FIGHT YOU'RE STILL FACING THE
COST OF LEGAL FIGHTS THAT'S OF
CONCERN AND THAT LEAVES US WITH
THE DEFENSIVE CONCERNED. AND IF
THE- COMMITTEE FEELS WE MUST
MAINTAIN WHICH IS THE ABILITY
TO TEST. AND I CLEAR- AND- TO
BE CLEAR THE- HASN'T DISCUSSED
EXPLICITLY. VOTERS POSSESS
IMPROPER SIXTY FOUR RIGHT EXT
DILLY PROTECTED THE ABILITY OF.
EMPLOYERS TO KEEP MARIJUANA THE
WORKPLACE. ON THE ROCKY RAGING
WIRE CAGE WHICH WAS TOUCHED ON
I'M JUST BRIEFLY EARLIER. IS.
I'M DEALING WITH A FEW
ACCOMMODATION UNDER MEDICAL.
RIGHT FOUNDED THE VOTERS THIS
IS UNDER PRIOR PROP TWO FIFTEEN
BUT THE LANGUAGE IS SIMILAR IN
PROP SIXTY. THE VOTERS. NOT
RIGHT INTO THE. MARIJUANA MUST
BE PAID IN THE WORKPLACE PEOPLE
CAN USE THIS LESSON CAN STEP
THAT HASN'T TAKEN BY THE VOTERS
AGAIN I WOULD ECHO I THINK.
MITCHELL WHICH CAN LEGISLATING
VIA INITIATIVE IS NOT IDEAL.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE PRESENTLY-
IN THIS AREA. AND IF I GET.
SOME THE OTHER WISE POINTS THAT
WERE RAISED I'M DEALING WITH
TESTING IN THE ISSUE
PERFORMANCE TO REYES. IT AHEAD
OF QUESTIONS BUT THAT SERVICE
ONE HOURS. SEVEN I. ENGLISH AND
TESTING SOME PERFORMANCE IS
ALSO AN IMPERFECT ISSUE HAVE
FOR POLICE ACTING RIGHT ISSUES
LIKE THAT I TWITCH WHEN YOU
LOOK A CERTAIN WAY. THE 5265%
ACCURATE. IN NOT A PERFECT
BAROMETER SO WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE SETTING. LOOK AT. THERE'S
JUST NOT THE PERFECT TEST OUT
THERE. YOU KNOW I LOOK FORWARD
TO IT GLAZER TEST I THINK IT'S
A COMPANY CALLED HOUND LAP
RECALL CORRECTLY. THAT WOULD BE
ON TWENTY TWENTY. SO I HOPE
THAT THOSE DEVELOP BETTER THAT
WOULD REALLY RESOLVE A LOT OF
CONCERN THIS ISSUE AND MAKE IT
EASIER EMPLOYERS WHO WOULDN'T
THAT IF THAT THAT. WHEN WITH
THE U. OF T. C. OR WOULD YOUR
LEVEL OF. HE IS AN ANAGRAM
HOWEVER IT'S RED. I MEAN IF YOU
DID A URINE TEST AND YOU HAVE.
THE A METABOLITE. THINK
METABOLIZED IN THERE THAT HOW
WOULD THAT AFFECT THAT.
OPPORTUNITY OR RIGHT. I'M NOT A
PERFECT I WILL BE A SCIENTIST
AND BREATH YEP BUT VIRTUE THE
BREATHALYZER TEST.
THEORETICALLY TESS RECENTLY
ENOUGH TO DETERMINE EXACTLY
WHEN IT WAS CONSUMES THE TERM
IF YOU'RE WITHIN THE LIKE END
OF IMPAIRMENT WHICH IS THE
PROBLEM TESTING YOU CAN'T
DETERMINE IT AND THAT WINDOW.
I'M SO THAT THAT'S THE IDEAL
DIFFERENTIATION MAKE IT
POTENTIAL TO NAIL DOWN IT IS
THIS TEST INDICATED. PRESENT
APPARENTLY. THERE WOULD NOT BE
ANY. DENIAL FOR THE. OPTION FOR
THE ANSWERS SORRY I'M SO NO
NOTE THAT OPTION WOULD BE
ATTAINABLE AND FLOSSING
HYPOTHETICAL. WHICH IS THE
SITUATION THE PROBLEM AND THAT
WOULD EMPLOYER WOULD MAKE THAT
DECISION WHETHER USE OF HONOR
THC AT SOME POINT IN THE LAST
THIRTY DAYS- THE PROBLEM OR NOT
A PROBLEM WHAT BUT THAT
DECISION EMPLOYERS FACED WITH
NOW IN THE AND I CAN'T
DETERMINE WHEN RIGHT- THAT TEST
WE HAVE BETTER DATA. AND I
CAN'T BE TOO YOU KNOW WHAT
SPECIFIC PLAYERS MIGHT CHOOSE
TO DO WITH THAT BETTER SCIENCE
BUT I'M HOPEFUL THAT WOULD
RESULT IN A CONCERT IT WOULD IS
ZERO TOLERANCE POLICY THEN HOW
WOULD THAT AFFECT THAT WE HAVE
ALLIES FOR THE- WITH AREN'T.
RIGHT IF YOU'RE FAT. I MEAN YOU
STILL CONSTRUCTING. WELL
WHENEVER IT FITS IN RIGHT OR
SOMEWHERE IN WHATEVER IT IS AS
TO HOW EMPLOYERS EGYPT JEWEL'S
POP AND PLAYERS SEE THEY MIGHT.
I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE CHOICES
THAT YOU. THINK THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW ANYWHERE. YEAH
IMPROVEMENT IN THE BENEFIT
THERE IS THE- BODY WITH ACCESS
TO BETTER DATA RIGHT TO ADDRESS
THIS QUESTION OF IMPAIRMENT
MORE PRECISE WAY AND TO. I CAN
GET TO A SECOND. WORKERS
COMPENSATION ONE OF THE ISSUES
THERE IS AN EXAMPLE I AGREE.
WITH THE ISSUES THAT COME.
WORKERS COMPENSATION- AND
THERE'S- YOUR WE HAVEN'T DEALT
WITH ONE OF ONE OF THEM IS.
INTOXICATE SENSES RIGHT AFTER
POST ACCIDENT TESTING AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. AND BECAUSE
TO HAVE A DEFENSE TO WORKERS
COMPENSATION BASED ON TALKS
ISSHIN RIGHT IF YOU HAVE TO
DEMONSTRATE IMPAIRMENT AND ONE
OF THE PROBLEMS ON OUR SIDE
RIGHT AS EMPLOYERS IS THAT YOU
AND- NAIL DOWN IMPAIR. THE
PRESENT TESTED SO LET'S SAY
THAT YOU HAVE AN EMPLOYER. THIS
DUMP I HAVE TO TURN IF THAT WAS
A FACTOR. MORE TROUBLING
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A GOOD
TIME. THAT'S GENERAL POINT
THERE- WE SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
OUT THERE WHEN IT. AN I. S.
DISTINCTION IT WASN'T DISCUSSED
IS FULLY LIKE THERE WERE
REFERENCES TO ALCOHOL ONE
BETTER TESTING. AT A SAID
EARLIER. BUT THE BREATHALYZER
YOU CAN TIGHTEN PARENT. RIGHT
HOPEFULLY WE GET. IS THERE
ANYTHING ELSE I WANT TO WORK SO
MANY GOOD POINTS MADE EARLIER-
FORGIVE ME I. MAY HAVE MISSED
SOME IS GOING THROUGH. NO WAY
OUT COULD CLEARLY GIVE- NICOLE
THE BRIEF POINT IS THE
EMPLOYERS. WE HAVE THOSE TWO
CIVIL CALLS RIGHT ENSURING
SAFETY IN THE WORKPLACE
AVOIDING ACCIDENTS CAN FOR.
TING REGIMES THE STATE AND
FEDERAL LEVEL AND AMBIGUOUS.
TESTING AN INCOMPLETE KNOWLEDGE
IT'S NOT A- SITUATION I WE WISH
IT WERE BETTER AND WE'RE
HOPEFUL IT WILL IMPROVE BUT- IT
STANDS WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO.
THE CITY CONCERT. IN IN WHAT
YOU DO WE- KNOWING YOU KNOW
CERTAIN. CURRENT DRUG TESTING
POLICY THE TROOPERS HAVE. IN
THE KNOWLEDGE YOU HAVE AND THAT
WE HAVE TODAY DID YOU PUT IT
BUYS THEM TO CHANGE THAT
BOTHERS POLICIES TO SOME OR
RECOMMEND. ROACH THAN WHAT WE
CURRENTLY ARE USING OR THEY'RE
ALL OF. THE WAY IT DOESN'T
MATTER SURE- WHY CAN'T. I'M HAS
INTIMATE BROAD RECOMMENDATIONS
OF. MEMBERSHIP AT. REFER BACK
TO THE FIRST PANELS COMMENTS
ON- THERE'S ON. THE BENEFITS
AND THE NEGATIVE THREAD I THINK.
BRANDT WAS OF HER CALL
CORRECTLY MADE THAT POINT QUITE
APT OUR MEDICAL BENEFITS AND
THEY'RE ALSO NEGATIVES ON
PERFORMANCE AND I'M IN TILL.
PRESIDENT CANNOT GIVE WISH YOU
COULD BUT IT WIN THE MATCH
NATIONAL SAY THEIR BENEFITS
AND- I THINK I WOULD BE REMISS
IF I STEPPED BEYOND THEM.
COMMENDATIONS. NO THAT'S
WONDERFUL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR. HOW ARE YOU.
THANK YOU. AND HE RETURNED.
ONCE AGAIN MY NAME IS NICOLE
RICE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS
AND TECHNOLOGIES ASSOCIATION
I'M WE ARE THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION THAT REPRESENTS
CALIFORNIA'S MORE THAN THIRTY
THOUSAND BACK IN COMPANIES THAT
EMPLOY ONE POINT THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIA. POSSIBLE FOR TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IN GROUPS STATE
PRODUCTS SO THAT'S ELEVEN
PERCENT. ITS WHOLE ECONOMIC
OUTPUT THAT COMES FROM OUR END.
WE APPRECIATE THIS CONVERSATION
I KNOW THERE'VE BEEN ON
DISCUSSIONS A LEGISLATURE AND
THE PASSED THROUGH LEGISLATION
SO MANUFACTURING COMMUNITY OF.
THAT WERE STARTING THE
DISCUSSION THAT MIGHT HAPPEN
THE FUTURE WITH THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. UP AND
IT'S POINT AND WHERE I'M
PLEASED TO BE HERE AT ARE
COMMENTED. HI THIS POLICY
DISCUSSION- TO BE I THINK WE'D
LIKE TO SAY IS OPENING
STATEMENTS. THIS ISSUE AS WE
INCREASE MAKERS AT TAKE A
MEASURE APPROACH TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF POLICIES ARE
NEEDED TO USE THE LEGALIZATION
OF CANNABIS USE WHETHER BE PAUL
OR RECREATIONAL ON THIS HEARING
A PORTENT TO US BECAUSE THERE
IS INFORMATION OUT THERE OF WE.
DATA AND I TO BIG DATA AND
MEDICAL DATA ALREADY. INFORM
ALL ASPECTS OF ALL THE PLAYERS
TO ENSURE. AS MENTIONED
COMMENTS THE REAL HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF ALL CALIFORNIANS MATT
STANDING THEY MIGHT FIND
THEMSELVES. EIGHT WHETHER IT'S
YOU KNOW RECREATIONAL ACTIVITY
FAMILY TIME EMPLOYMENT. A LOT
WE WERE. HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS IS IN THIS
AREA SO ONE OF THE THINGS. WE
WANT TO TALK ABOUT IS THE
UNIQUE OF MANUFACTURING. WE ARE
A SAFETY SENSITIVE INDUSTRY AS.
INDUSTRIAL SPACE YOU HAVE ON IT
HE QUIT MEN'S YOU HAVE.
HAZARDOUS MATERIAL BE HANDLED
MOBILE THE EQUIPMENT. MAN SO
SAFETY IS. IT'S A KEY VALUE TO
YOU CALIFORNIA'S A
MANUFACTURING MEMBER. P. A.'S
MAP. PLEASE IN THOSE
ENVIRONMENTS AND TO HAVE FULL
CONTROL AND BE ALONE AND HOW
FULL ALERTNESS TO AVOID REALLY
LIFE ALTERING AND LIFE
THREATENING INJURIES IF
SOMEONE- IF THEIR MEMORIES
IMPAIR IT FOR THEIR SAFETY
TRAINING AND IT. A. L. YOU KNOW
I HAVE FULL OF THEIR THEIR
MENTAL CAPACITY THE CASE MAY BE
AND THEY'RE WORKING WITH. AND
WE SAFETY YOU MUST REAL QUICK
MED AND PRODUCT WE CAN HAVE
QUESTIONS WERE PEOPLE ARE
GETTING INJURED SO EARLY SO
THEY'RE LOSING LANDS THEY'RE
LOSING. OFFICE THERE'S PROPERTY
DAMAGE FROM THE YOU KNOW THE
COMPANIES PER ACTIVE SO THAT'S
PRODUCT THAT WE HAVE TO START
THE PROCESS ALL OVER AGAIN. AND
THEY'RE LOSING THEIR LOT. IT'S
NOT JUST YOUR LIFE BUT IT'S THE
LIFE OF THEIR WORKERS AS WELL
THE MANUFACTURING COMMUNITIES
IN THE FACILITY. MUCH OF
COMMUNITY THE TEAM BASED IN
TEAM BUILDING SO EVERYONE NEEDS
TO BE. VERY SHARP VERY ALERT.
ACTION OF THE ENTIRE TEAM AND
THEREFORE THE ENTIRE FACILITY.
SO MANY MANUFACTURERS OF NOT
ALL. ACTORS OF THE ZERO
TOLERANCE DRUG USE POLICIES FOR
THAT I RESPECT AND TO THE
EARLIER QUESTION FROM USER
CHAIR. I'LL CHAIRMAN HEALTH- AS
TO YOU KNOW TYPE OF TESTING YOU
MIGHT. AND YOU KNOW IS IT
HAPPENING AT PRE APPOINTMENT
ARE INODE RANDOM SCENE AFTER
YOUR EMPLOYER IT ALL OVER THE
US THE SPACE FOR MY MEMBERS. IT
HAPPENED IN THE PRE EMPLOYMENT
SCREENING CAN HAPPEN WHILE
YOU'RE ALREADY LATE IT CAN BE.
BEING A COULD BE SCHEDULED
TESTING IT ALL DEPENDS ON WHAT
YOUR ROLE RESPONSIBILITY IS IN
THAT PROP. AND THE POLICIES OF
THAT COMPANY SO I WANTED TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT COULD
WIPE. THEM WHY THAT'S IMPORTANT.
PUBLISHED ONE AS A ROBERT
MENTIONED IT'S FEDERAL YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE THE FEDERAL
PROHIBITION RELATED TO THIS
SCHEDULE ONE NARCOTIC AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND MY COMPANIES
BECAUSE WERE MANUFACTURERS
BECAUSE OF MANUFACTURES AND
BECAUSE OF WHAT WE DO. WERE
EITHER DIRECTLY CONTRACTING
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR
WE HAVE CUSTOMERS WHO ARE
EITHER DIRECTLY CONTRACTING OR
ARE IN STATES THAT DON'T HAVE.
THESE LEGAL USES FOR CANNABIS
AND SO THEY HAVE IN THEIR CAR
TRACKS THAT YOU CANNOT ALLOW
FOR BASING YOUR FACILITY SO
WHEN WE ENTER INTO THAT
CONTRACT WERE BITING. THOSE
REQUIREMENTS OF OUR CUSTOM SOME
OF THE CONTRACTS HAVE IN PLACE
FOR YEARS FOR DECADES AND SO
THERE'S A GREAT. MANUFACTURING
TO BE AS RELATES TO THOSE THOSE
CUSTOMER CONTRACTS. IF YOU HAVE
TO GO BACK INTO GHOST THOSE
CONTRACTS PUTTHOSE TERMS AND
CONDITIONS BACK ON THE TABLE
THEY MIGHT. SEEN AS A VIABLE IT
YOU KNOW CONTRACTING PARTNER
BECAUSE OF ONE PARTICULAR
CONCERN SO ALL OF. ON PROBATION
RELATED TO CANNABIS CLOUDS
ALONG. I'M SECONDLY IT'S THE
LIABILITY SO AS I TALKED ABOUT
INJURIES THAT CAN HAPPEN. WE
HAVE A LOT OF WORKER
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE IN THE
WORKPLACE. AND OVER LEAVE THAT
THERE'S AN INJURY IN THE
WORKPLACE IT IT THE EMPLOYER DO
THEIR DUE DILIGENCE TO PREVENT
OR PROTECT FOR THAT INJURY
HAPPENING SO TESTING IS A- BIG
PART OF THAT FOR ME AND- IN THE
SAFETY SENSITIVE INDUSTRIAL
SPACES SO WE'RE MAKING. FOR
THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
WORKING IN VARIOUS DIFFERENT
ELEMENTS OF THE MANUFACTURING
PROCESS OR- YOU THE. OF THE
JOB. TO DO THE ASCENT FUNCTIONS
OF THAT SHOP. YOU SEE ANY TYPE
OF IMPAIRMENT IN THEIR ABILITY
TO FUNCTION IN THOSE A CENTRAL
RESPONSIBILITIES. WHETHER IT
WHATEVER IS CAN IS A OR CAUSING
THAT IMPAIRMENT THEN WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF WAYS OF DEALING WITH
THAT ANOTHER QUESTION YOU WERE
AT SHERMAN HILL SOMETIMES IT'S
DETERMINE. IS CORRECT SO MY
COMPANY TAP METAL POLE PASILA
TEASE AT. ON SITE SO MAYBE
THERE'S GOING TO IT. PATIENTS
SO THAT PERSON IS REMOVED FROM
THE JOB. UNTIL THEY CAN FIGURE
OUT IF THEY YOU KNOW FAT TO BE
ABLE TO DO THOSE ESSENTIAL
FUNCTION SOMETIMES IT'S YOU
KNOW SOMETIMES REMOVAL MIGHT BE
PUTTING THEM DIFFERENT PLACE
BUT SOMETIMES MIGHT ALSO BE
SENDING THEM HOME INTO THAT
EVALUATION CAN HOUSE. THERE'S
ALSO IN IN VARIOUS BY YOU
ASIANS THAT MIGHT OCCUR THERE'S
G. SAYS EMBEDDED IN THAT SO IF
THE EMPLOYER DISAGREES WITH YOU
KNOW WHAT THE. FIGHT ENGINE IS
THERE'S A PROCESS IN PLACE FOR
THEM TO A. SO THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS. THAT CAN BE DONE. AND
THEN ALL OF. IS WITH THE
MANUFACTURER'S KEEPING IN MIND
THAT THEY JUST DON'T WANT TO
DISMISS. THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
EVIDENCE BUT THEY HAVE TO DO
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO ME.
THAT FACILITY FOR THE CUP AND
THAT INDIVIDUAL IN BEING
COMPLIANT LAWS OF CAL OSHA
THEIR SAFETY LAWS AND SUCH- THE
OTHER THING I WANTED TO HAVE
ON. THE RELIABLE CASTING SO MY
MEMBERS PHIL RESOUND THAT UNTIL
WE CAN BE ABLE TO BET. HERMAN
THE IMPAIRED MISS. USING CANNON
EITHER MET FOR MEDICAL REASONS
OR FOR RECREATIONAL REASON AND
COMING INTO THE WORKPLACE AND
THEIR ABILITY TO DO THE CENTRAL
FUNCTIONS OF THAT JOB IF THE
SENSITIVE ENVIRONMENT. THEN WE
CANNOT LACKS ORTEZ. IT NEEDS TO
BE THERE THAT FIRST LINE OF
DEFENSE THERE IT. DISCUSSIONS
THAT CAN BE. YES ARENA I THINK
AND WE'RE BALANCING LIABILITY
LIKE I SAID. SOME OF THE EVER
CAN THANK YOU SO MUCH J. FOR
SHARING THAT WHAT SOME OTHER
STATES ARE DOING. MY AGE OUR
FOLKS ARE SAYING YOU CAN ALWAYS
LOOK AT WHAT OTHER STATES. AND
A AS CALIFORNIA LET'S GO AHEAD
ADOPT OUT WHOLE HEARTEDLY
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LAW OR
PROGRESS. A LADY AND SO YOU LAW
AND STICK INTO THAT SITUATION
MAKES IT VERY. VERY DIFFICULT
FOR US TO COMPLY SO WE HAVE TO.
NINETEEN SB. OFTEN FACILITIES
AND OTHER DIFFERENT STATES.
CORPORATE ALL OF THE VARIOUS.
SECTIONS BUT JUST AT THE
OPPORTUNITY WE ALSO SEE THE
BERRY. BALANCING ACT SO WE'RE
HAPPY TO BE PART OF THIS CALL
ASIAN. ONE EIGHT LEGISLATURE AS
I SAID IN MY OLD COMMENT TAKE A
MEASURED APPROACH. SUGGESTION
COULD BE AS OTHER LAWS. EXEMPTS
SAFETY SENSITIVE INDUSTRIES
BECAUSE I THINK EVERY PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. CAME TO WORK AND- SO
WE'RE HAPPY TO BE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION WE APPRECIATE WHAT
IS TAKING PLACE TODAY AND I AM.
QUESTIONS THAT I MIGHT BE ABLE
TO ANSWER THANK YOU. I THINK.
THE FACT THAT THE CANNABIS.
IMPAIRMENT. I THINK GOING VERY
DECISIVE AND. IN THE SYSTEM IN
THE INDUSTRY IN IN EVERY LEVEL
OF. EXACTLY WHERE YOU THE
TESTING OF THE NOT TESTING AND
HOW IT WORKS. HOW OFTEN. I
THINK THIS IS THE SCRIPT SENATE
MITCHELL THANK YOU- I
APPRECIATE YOUR DESIRE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE TAKE A VOTE I THINK
THE VOTERS TO AN OPTION WE FROM
AFTER THE PROPERTY FOR I THINK
I'D CERTAINLY WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT GO THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AT.
VERTICALLY BUDGET IT WOULD. BE
FOR IT. ASK US WHAT WOULD BE A
GREAT TATIAN DATE FOR YOU. THEY
DIDN'T THEY- EIGHT THAT WE THAT
HAVE WHY WITH SO. WHICH IS WHY
I DON'T. MALES FACTORS THE
STEPS ARE TAKEN IN. I HAVE A
GOOD. A COUPLE OF YEARS DURING
THE INTERIM AND BREAKS- TO READ
IN MEETING WITH MANUFACTURERS
IN MY DISTRICT I HAVE SURPRISE
AT. THE HEARING NUMBER OF
MANUFACTURERS. YOU KNOW A VERY
URBAN DISTRICT BUT I HAVE QUITE
A FEW I REPRESENT A GOOD
PORTION. BRING AREAS AND FIRST
A LOT. AND SO. ON THAT IN HERE
AND YOU. AND I APPRECIATE THAT
THE IN A ROUND. THE BILL THE I
WANT TO DO ONE'S JOB SAFELY. I
THINK. CANADA I WILL KLAY
BECAUSE OF AFFECTED. COLLEGE
YEAH THINK ABOUT SLEEP
DEPRIVATION WHEN I THINK ABOUT.
THE SICK DISTRACTION THE TIMES
ON CELL PHONES AND TEXTING ALL
IN ALL WORKPLACE. AND THOSE ARE
THINGS WERE TEST. WE'RE NOT YOU
KNOW I DON'T KNOW IF IN.
PERCEPTION OF IT AND IF WE'RE
NOT REALLY LOOKING AT IT. TERMS
UP ARE THE TRUE CAUSES OF
DANGEROUS INCIDENTS CRITICALLY
MANUFACTURING SPACES. THANK YOU
EVERYONE'S GOT ONE THE AND HAS
A NEED TO LOOK AT DISTRACTED
BY- AS OPPOSED TO PROP- OUGHT
NUMBER FROM FULL WHO ARE
ENGAGED IN IT IS NOW. A LEGAL
SUBSTANCE IN OUR STATE. NO I
APPRECIATE THAT AND SENATOR
MITCHELL AND. HERE THAT YOU'RE
GETTING OUT IN AND LOOK AT THE
INDUSTRY- SO THEY ARE HE
TRAINING AND PERCY AND SUCH.
MINIMIZE DISTRACTIONS AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE WE ARE EMPLOYEES
YOU WON'T SEE OUR EMPLOYEES IF
YOU TAKE IT AS YOU TAKE. YOU
KNOW THERE ARE SPECIFIC PLACES
WHERE YOU'RE WALKING WHEN
YOU'RE WALKING YOU'RE NOT ON
YOUR PHONE I MEAN I RECENTLY
JUST VISIT ONE OF OUR LARGER ME
ACTORS ON IT SAN DIEGO AREA AND
THEY SENT US A BIT. BEFORE I TO
NOT OKAY BUT THEN GO ON LINE
AND ANSWER A FEW QUESTIONS SO
THAT THEY KNEW THAT WE SAW
BEFORE EVEN GET THROUGH THE
DOOR TO DO THE TO AND WHERE THE
REPRESENTED OF THE INDUSTRY SO
OUR SAFETY PROCEDURES ARE VERY-
VERY STRICT. AND WE TAKE THEM.
INSTEAD COMPREHENSIVE THAT'S
CORRECT OKAY TO THE ISSUE OF
CANADA I THINK WE- LAWYER ANY
MORE STRONGLY. NOT A NOT
PERMISSION NODE RIGHT ABOUT
THIS. IT'S NOT JUST A LEVEL OF
IMPAIRMENT DON'T EVEN HAVE A
STAFF PRESERVATION FOR
IMPAIRMENT TO CANNABIS USE.
ROBERT AND I COULD TAKE THE
SAME AMOUNT. DOES HAVE THE HE
DOES. YEAH ABOUT THAT I AM TYPE
ONE DIABETIC WELL THAT IS.
AFTER THAT GOING TO IT. MY USE
OF CANNABIS COULD BE COULD BE
EXTREMELY NEGATIVE SO EVERY
INDIVIDUAL HAS A NEW ONES THAT
WE IS THE EMPLOYER SOME OF THE
STATE HE EVEN ASKED. CAN'T DIG
INTO THE. MEDICAL HISTORY BY
ASKING C<c.cyan>. FIGURE THAT OUT</c>
PROHIBITED AGAIN BY SO THERE
ARE A LOT OF LAWS THAT ARE
INTERSECTING INVITING US YES HE
JUST MAKING THINGS IS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THE LAWYER TO BE
ABLE TO GREAT THIS IN A WAY
THAT WE CAN HAVE ENOUGH NOT.
WE'RE SENDING SOMEONE INTO A
SICK PLACE AND THAT IS THERE.
THAT THEY WILL BE SAFE AND THEY
WILL AIR TO SAFETY PROCEDURES
THAT WILL ENSURE THAT. THERE
WAS EARLIER JUST A PRESCRIPTION
DRUG YEAH I'M THERE MIGHT BE
THIS PERCEPTION THAT EMPLOYERS
IF SOMEBODY IS USING
PRESCRIPTION DRUG THEN THEY'RE
SAYING MS. WE'RE USING THE THIS
PRESCRIPTION DRUG AND WE HEY
THAT'S FINE AND- OTHER
DISCUSSION NOT THE CASE I CAN.
LAST YEAR WERE. INTO A BILL
THAT TRYING TO EQUATE THE USE
OF. TO THE TREATMENT OF FIRST
FOR PRESCRIPTION. QUESTION
RIGHT WHAT'S HAPPENING IT'S- IT.
THIRD PARTY IF YOU WILL. ASH
WHAT THE SIDE EFFECTS ARE. HEY
AS A REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION.
MEDICATION YOU NEED TO TAKE IT
TO WHAT. FROM THE FDA THE
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS THAT THIS
DRUG START DISSIPATE IN THE
SYSTEM AND THEREFORE DOZEN IN
ACT REACT. YOU KNOW AUDIT BUT
OUR THAT'S INFORMATION WE JUST
A- FOR CANADA AND SO THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS THAT YOU TO TAKE.
ORDER FOR US AGAIN AS MAN YOU
FACT. SAFE SINCE THE END. SURE
THE SAFETY OF OUR WORKFORCE
BECAUSE THEY'RE COUNTING ON US
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT. I WOULD
JUST THANK YOU FOR THAT I WOULD
JUST SAY YOUR TO THE- THIS IS A
SPACE. WHERE YOU NEED TO BE
LEADING MAN. AND WHILE WE'RE
ALL HOPING TODAY IN HEARING
CHALLENGES KIND OF. THIS I
WOULD. THE BOAT- DID YOU GIVE
US AN OPPORTUNITY. AND SO THE
SPACE WHERE AS A CHAMBER. IN
THINKING ABOUT THE NUMBERS THAT
THE FIRST PANEL SHARED WITH
THAT YOU'RE- DELETED. IN TERMS
OF I DIDN'T FIND SOLUTIONS. YES
THAT'S WHY CAN BRING WITH. TO
BE LEADERS WE ALWAYS LIKE TO DO
WE CAN ON IT I THINK ONE OF THE
ISSUE IS THAT THE FIRST PANEL.
IN THIS AREA THERE. SO MANY
DIFFERENT. STEPS RIGHT HELLO
I'VE PRIOR TO THIS MUNICIPAL
LAW. STEP SIX FEDERALLY TO
BRING THIS TO A PLACE THAT
WOULD CHANGE THE CHANGE THAT
SURROUNDING PIECE FOR BUSINESS.
THAT'S I THINK HOPEFULLY THINGS
WILL CHANGE AS TO POLICY.
YOU'LL COMPANIES DIFFERENT
POLICIES THAT SOME HAVE CHOSEN
TO STOP. BECAUSE THEY FOUND
THAT THAT WAS SO IF SOME
EMPLOYEES RIGHT. I CAN'T YOU
KNOW I PREFER NOT TO SPEAK THE
INDIVIDUAL POLICIES WERE VERY
BROAD GROUP YEAH BUT SOMEHOW IN
THAT. NOT I'M HOPEFUL THAT AS
IN THAT WE TALKED. ABOUT STATES
THE LABORATORIES OF DEMOCRACY
MAYES AT HER EARLIER. ALL
COMPANIES THAT WILL TAKE THOSE.
HOPEFULLY WILL HELP THE
INDUSTRY IN A WAY THAT WILL BE
BACK. BUT STILL MANY ANGLES
HERE THAT I I'M HESITANT TO
COMMIT MORE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. I CENTER THANK GOD FOR THE
TESTIMONY COMMENTS WAS VERY
INFORMATIVE. OUR FINAL PANEL
TODAY IS- PAPER STAKEHOLDERS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HIGH SKILL
HIGH WAGE JOBS JEFF FERRO
JUSTIN AT THE NET IN COMMERCIAL
WORKERS. AND BUCK DIRECTOR OF
THE TEAMSTERS CANNABIS DIVISION.
COME WICKS WORK. FOR WHAT HOW
ARE YOU WONDERFUL THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR PARTICIPATING
TODAY. YOUR FIRST OUR ORDER
SURE. YES I'M JEFF FERAL I
ACTUALLY BECAME THE DIRECTOR OF
THE U. W.'S. I HAVE ALSO
PROJECT EXECUTIVE ASSISTANT FOR
THE DIRECT ORGANIZING FOR THE
UFCW. BUT I HAVE BEEN. TO YES.
WELL ABOUT THE UC W'S BEEN
ORGANIZING CANNABIS WORKERS
BEFORE THAT- IN FACT- ONE OF
YOUR SACRAMENTO LOCAL OPERATE.
THE FIRST- CONTRACTED THERE'S
AN LIKE MID TWO THOUSAND THE
EARLY TWO THOUSAND AN HAS BEEN
OFFERED YOU KNOW AS A SINGLE
SMALL OPERATORS BEEN ABLE TO
GROWN IS NOW. WE ALRIGHT.
THROUGH CONTRACTS EMPLOYERS AND
FOURTEEN IN CANADA. REPRESENT
WORKERS FROM SEED TO SAIL IN
MANUFACTURING TESTING LABS XIN
LABS DELIVERY HERS- WORKERS
THAT WORK IN RETAIL SPACE SO
THERE'S NOT REALLY AN OCCUPANT.
REPRESENT UP AND SO WE'VE HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO SEE THE
CHALLENGE OF THOSE. THE UNIQUE
PART ABOUT THAT IS THAT PART OF
THE CHALLENGE THE EMPLOYERS
TALKED ABOUT OUR CHALLENGES
THAT ARE WORKERS I'M FACES WELL
THEIR ABILITY TO GET OURS AND
QUALITY. AND THE QUALITY AND
BENEFITS ARE DIRECTLY TIED TO
THE WORKERS THAT ARE WORKING IN
THE ILLEGAL MARKET THAT ARE NOT.
TO THE SAME STANDARDS ARE NOT
GETTING END OF. SEASON ONE.
RETIREE BENEFITS MEMBERS GET
THE HEALTH AND WELFARE BENEFITS
OUR MEMBERS GET THE EDUCATIONAL
ASSISTANT SOME OF THEM GET. AS
FOR THEIR. AND OF COURSE WHEN
IS A BIG THING. THE BANKING A
LOT BECAUSE WITHIN THE SPACE
HAVE CHALLENGES OF GETTING
LOANS BE ABLE TO GET A CAR
DEALERSHIP POINT. THE SEVENTH
ST. LEADING BOTH HERE AND AT
THE FEDERAL MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S BANKING ACCESS AND SO
SOME OF THE BANKING STUFF IS
WAITIN FOR. OF VOTE SENATE.
THE LEVEL OF YOU KNOW WE
PROVIDE A LOT OF TESTIMONY AND
WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS TO GIVE
TESTIMONY. WE WILL BE ABLE TO.
KEEP TING PENTA ALLOWING TAX.
PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE TWO EIGHTY
TURN BECAUSE OF THE FEDERAL LAW
THAT SAYS THAT. IS CAN'T WRITE
OFF THEIR COSTS. TERM OUR
EMPLOYEES BECAUSE OF THE
EQUIPMENT CAN BUY OF THAT COMES
DIRECTLY OUT OF THE BOTTOM LINE
OF THE EMPLOYER BUT THAT'S
EQUIPMENT THAT YOU'RE JOBS
BETTER THEIR JOB SAY. IT IS
ALSO THE KIND OF MONEY THAT
USED TO PAY FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
AND TRAINING PROCESSES TO THESE
AND IN THAT AND THEY CONTINUE
LEAST ONES WE WORK WITH. A JOB
WITH BENEFITS AND WORKING
CONDITIONS THE U. OF C. W. IN
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE. DOESN'T
LEVEL WE STARTED OF- A NATIONAL
RAM OF NOT JUST THE CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM AND SINCE. FEDERAL LAWS
WE GOT THE AND TO HELP
EMPLOYERS AND AGAIN WE GOT THE-
YES SIR JURISDICTION ON A CASE
IN MAINE. AND THAT PROVIDE A
WAY FOR US TO START LOOKING AT
HOW DO WE GET HELPFUL FOR PLANS
NOW. FOR THAT WE ARE WITH IF
THEY CHOOSE TO SPEND EITHER
INTO OR OUT OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE. BOTH
THEM AND THEIR EMPLOYERS I MEAN
THE MANAGERS. SAME WITH RETIREE
BENEFITS AND THEN WE STARTED
REALLY TACKLING. WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SO. FOURTEEN WIDE
FOR PERMISSION BERMAN THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE BEGAN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THAT. NUMBER ONE
HAS THE ONLY STATES DEFIED
JOURNEY PERSON. THE WORK HERE
IN TOWN IN SACRAMENTO THAT WAS
GRADUATED AND- CERTIFIED. THE
JOURNEY PERSON AT THIS INDUSTRY
WE BELIEVE IMPORTANT- JUST FOR
THAT WORK BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THIS INDUSTRY ABOUT PROCESSES
THE WITH A MAYBE. AN ABYSS
WHICH SOME PEOPLE REALLY
NERVOUS ABOUT. PROCESSES
WHETHER CULTIVATE. THING ELSE
WHETHER THEIR PROCESSING. A LOT
OF OUR INDUSTRY. CAN WE
REPRESENT ARMOS UTICA
MANUFACTURES SENT AGRICULTURAL
VOTERS SENT IN BY ISRAELI
FACTORS IN PESTICIDE MAKERS FOR
THOSE FOLKS AS WELL WE
REPRESENT ME CUTTERS REGULATED.
FRIENDSHIP FOR THE- OF CARE
PROVIDERS AND WE HAVE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS FOR
THEM OR. SO WE THINK THAT THESE
ARE SKILLED BASE FROM. THAT WE
CAN DO THAT IF THE STATE
CERTIFIES FOLKS IS HAVING A
STATE CERTIFIED. THAT. TO BE
ABLE TO TALK ABOUT I AM YOU
HAVE A STATE CERTIFIED
WORKFORCE OF THIS PLACE. OUR
STATE AND WE THINK THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT ALLOWS
THE IMP USED TO DEMAND BETTER
AS- HAVE A MORE SECURE
WORKPLACE AND IT ALSO ALLOWS
THEM TO. MANY FACTORIES BEEN
LEAVING OUR COUNTRY CAMPUS IS
DEGENERATING INTERESTED
MANUFACTURER CULTIVATE. FOR
BUSINESSES LEAVING OUR COUNTRY
BUT YOUNG PEOPLE ARE. CANNABIS
AND ALL THE DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT GO ALONG WITH THAT AND
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO BE INTEREST
THING THAT WE'RE LOSING
INTERESTED WE'VE TURNED INTO A
SEARCH ON THE STREET IN THIS
COUNTRY AND THIS IS REAP ALL
THE ASPECTS THAT OUR COUNTRY
HAS BEEN SOME OF THE- VERY BEST
AT. SO THIS PROGRAM ARMY. YOU
KNOW GOOD MONEY GREAT IT'S HAVE
STABILITY. YOUR QUESTIONS ABOUT
PEOPLE GETTING TESTED YOU HAVE
A CONTRACT THAT HAS. GRIEVANCE
OR VISIT OUR PROCEDURE WE WILL
WIN WORKERS THE FACT THAT IT
HAVE A MEDICAL CARD BETTER ABLE
TO PROVE THAT THEY WERE UNDER
THE INFLUENCE FALL. ON ONE OF
THE OFFICE THE TABLE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I THINK ARE GONNA
HELP US AND THE PART THE LEFT
IS THE RECENT PASSAGE. I THINK
IT'S TWELVE NINETY ONE WHICH.
WE GOT THAT EARLY ON HERE IN
THE MEDICAL AND WAS EXTENDED
ADULT USE AND IT'S BEEN REALLY
HARD TO GET SOME CLARITY ON
WHAT REALLY IS GOING TO HAPPEN
IF WE PRESSED IN. ON IT. AND I
THINK THAT'S GONNA HELP WITH-
RAISING THE STANDARDS FOR ALL
WRITERS HERE. I THINK THERE'S
REALLY THREE THINGS ALSO YOU
NEED TO LOOK AT WHICH IMPACT
ARE PART. OF THEIR ABILITY.
CHALLENGES AND YOU HEARD IT
FROM BOTH LAWYERS AND SMALL
BOX. IT'S THE ENFORCEMENT. IT'S
THE TAXATION AND IT'S THE BANDS.
THE BAND'S PEOPLE LET'S SEE.
I'M SOMEWHAT. BIG OPPORTUNITY
FOR PEOPLE IN THE ILLEGAL
MARKET. IF THERE IS A ROBUST
ENFORCEMENT. END UP HAPPENING
IS. MOTHER FOLKS IT'LL DRIVE.
WE'LL GET ILL LIKE THE VAPING.
THEN TAXATION IN. REALLY HARD
FOR THESE PEOPLE TO COMPETE.
ALLIES ONES THAT ARE ABLE TO
MAKE IT WE TALKED. THIS TO- YOU
KNOW THE DISSENT TRIES THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE IMPACTED DRUGS
MAKING IT. DIVERSITY IN EQUITY
IN THE SENATE. THE CHALLENGES.
WITH THE CAP. WITH THE LACK OF
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE ACCESS TO
TRAINING. THE EXPERIENCE THAT
BY A PRODUCT THAT SAFETY
CONSUMERS. PERSON FRANKLY SAFE
TO ALL OF YOU THAT. IN THIS
MYSTERY BECAUSE LET'S FACE IT
THE CHALLENGES THAT YOU FACE OR
IF ALL GOES UP. THE TERM. ON
THE WHAT PLAGIARISM THE
GOVERNORS THERE SIGNED BOB THIS
TO HAPPEN. BECAUSE EVEN
APPROVED IT THEY'RE STILL GOING
TO EXPECT YOU TO PUT. THAT YOU
SERVE. THINGS LIKE THAT THAT
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
INDUSTRY TO STABLE AS THIS.
WHICH WILL ALLOW US. AS FOR
FIRST. BRING THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR CLUB. THE RIGHT TO BE A
WHISTLEBLOWER IF SOMETHING'S
GOING BAD IN A BAD EMPLOYER IT
ALLOWS AND THE FIRST LINE. OF
ENFORCEMENT ARE MEMBERS OF THE
FIRST. SOMETHING'S GOING WRONG
THEY COULD TRY TO HANDLE IT
INTERNALLY. IT DOESN'T GET RID.
WHAT THE CUSTOMER THEY'VE THEY
REALLY CARE. ALMOST A
CONNECTION OF MAIN ISSUE.
WORKERS WERE CONCERNED WITH AN
EMPLOYER OR PUTTING. SIDES ALL
PRODUCT AT THE END OF THE- BY
SPECKLED. THE CONCERNS OF HOW
THAT MIGHT. DEFICIENCIES I'M
SURE WORKERS GET SICK. IT'S GOT
SICK. THE US TO HELP THEM AND
THAT'S REALLY HOW. HE DROVE THE
KILLER BE PROCESSED WITH THE
INDUSTRY SO IF YOU REQUEST.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED SIDE HI
THERE THANKS FOR HAVING ME WHEN
YOU BECAUSE NOT ALL BLOCKING.
STIRS CANNABIS DIVISION I'M I'M
GONNA. JUST. ABOUT JOBS IN THE
ASIAN AND WHAT CANNABIS AND
WITH THAT INDUSTRY CAN ACTUALLY.
HELLO ALSO THE NATION. HE AND
IT'S PROJECT THAT CANNABIS
REGULATED LEGAL CANNABIS WILL
CREATE ABOUT. JOBS THROUGHOUT
THE NAY WHICH SUBSTANTIAL.
AMOUNT OF WORKERS I. ONE OF THE
FASTEST GROWING INDUSTRIES IS.
TREES UP AT EIGHT COME ONLINE
AND THAT'S. SO TO TALK BRIEFLY
ABOUT THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
JOBS. ASK THE CATION. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT RETAIL WORKERS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT DELIVERY
EVERS TRANSPORT DRIVERS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SECURE. FREE
BUSINESS SAYS- GROW AND-
TRIMMERS PEOPLE THAT WORK IN
CULTURAL ASPECTS SO THIS ISN'T
JUST. ABOUT WHAT. RETAIL IS
ACTUALLY COVERING LIKE JEFF
SAID. SALE. IS OF FOLKS BEGIN
ANYWHERE BETWEEN A BUDGET CAN
MAKE THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
THIRTY. MASTER GROWERS IN
TRACTORS CAN MAKE UP TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR- THEY RANGE IS REALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO SET UP STAND. UP
FOR THIS IS DO YOU HAPPEN
MENTION THAT YOU HAVE. IS THAT
VARY FROM CITY TO COUNTY.
PLAYING FIELD THERE- THE
TEAMSTERS OF NEGOTIATED
CONTRACTS AND RAISED WE- TWENTY
SIX DOLLARS AN HOUR FOR
DISTRIBUTION DRIVERS WHICH WE
FEEL IS A IS A WILL H. SO I'M I
WAS ASKED SPECIFICALLY WHAT
UNIONS CAN DO FOR THIS INDUSTRY.
AND WHY WERE HERE AT TEN
QUESTION MEANT WE DO HAVE A
ROOF. FRAME IS THE HAS TWENTY
OR MORE EMPLOYEES TO ENGAGE
WITH THE LETTER UNION HAVE
LABOR PEACE. AND SOME OF THE
OPERATORS THAT YOU. I HAVE
ENGAGE WITH UP OF THE STAB YOU
IN THE TEAMSTERS. WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO AND WHAT LABOR IN.
AND I KNOW JEFF AS WELL. HE WAS
REALLY SET A STANDARD SO WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE TAKING IT
GROUND ILLICIT MARKET. BRINGING
IT UP OUT OF THE SHOW. WITH A
GROUP OF WORKERS THAT HAVE NOT
HAD WORKERS. AND SOME OF OUR
GREAT IN FEAR AND I RECEIVE
PHONE CALLS AND THIS IS THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE. EITHER. PAID SO
THOSE STERN- ARE STILL WELL IN
THERE. WORKERS WITH WORK IF
SUCH AS UNSAFE WORKING
CONDITIONS LONG HOURS UNDER
PATIENT LOW PAY WAITSTAFF WE
SEEK A WORK ENVIRONMENT THAT.
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT
IN REGARDS. CAMPUS AND WE SEE
PROTECTION FOR WORKERS SUCH AS
PER YOUR USING PESTICIDES.
WE'LL SAFE SAFELY ENSURING THAT
OUR. OPERATE IN SAFE CONDITIONS
IN HOURS. DRIVERS WHO ARE OUT
OF PUBLIC TO ACTUALLY WEAR
PROTECTIVE BULLETPROOF VESTS
AND THESE WORKERS ARE NOT PART
AB SIDE OF A DISPENSARY WITH A
GUARD AT THE DOOR. TRANSPLANT
THAT. AND CASH ON CALIFORNIA
RIGHT. THIS WAS A RIGHT HAD TO
ACTUALLY FOR FOUR AND ONE
BECAUSE THE COMPANY ASKED OUR
DRIVERS TO NOT WITH THEM. YOU
KNOW. THE CONDUIT BETWEEN
WORKERS AND MANAGEMENT. CATION.
PENSION AND HEALTH IS WEALTH IS
THAT OUR OB AT DISCOUNT RATE
ALSO BETTER PAY. MANY YEARS AGO
THE TEAMSTERS WERE FILED IN
HELPING SHAPE NO CLASS INTO
THIS FIGHT TODAY NOW MORE. THAN
EVER IN OUR NATION. THE BILL IS
THE WAIVER. SINCE THE GAP
BETWEEN THE OLD. FILL THAT ONE
SHOT. YOU SHOULD GET A LIVING
WAGE. WILL IT COME FAMILIES AND
THAT INSTEAD YOUR SECOND JOB.
ENORMOUS JOB GROWTH THE KING
HAS PROVIDED ORGANIZATION IS TO
ENSURE THAT. ENDS WITH IF IT'S
A IS THAT CAN SUSTAIN A ROBUST
MIDDLE CLASS. THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE. THANK YOU. THE
ISSUE. THAT THAT THAT SEEM TO
BE CONSUMERS. TWO TWO AND
DEFINE THE STANDARD HOW IT
WOULD DO. WITH THAT. BUT WE.
THE HARD SPACE TO BE BECAUSE OF
THEIR. TAKE PLACE AND- THE I
DON'T EAT THEM BUT SOMETIMES WE
CAN CROSS REEFER MADNESS. IF
THERE ARE. MAINTAIN AND TRYING
TO WE WENT TO BUY PRODUCT IN
YOUR ABILITY TO PEOPLE. SOME
HAVE CHANGED. HI ELLEN PHONE
FROM NORTH. THEY FAR AHEAD OF
US. JUST CANNABIS MARKET. BUT
WHERE WE DO HAVE THE TEAMSTERS.
LIKE DENVER WHERE THESE ARE
THINGS WHERE WE. YOU
PROTECTIONS FOR WORK.
GOVERNMENT CARD HERE USING THE
THING YOU CAN DO TO HELP. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE
AND THAT. IT'S A GOOD
INFORMATION. NOW OPEN TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IS ANYONE. COME TO
SHARE YOUR THOUGHTS THAT WOULD
BE WONDERFUL. THIS ASSOCIATION
SPENCER IS OUT OF OUR SO IN
CALIFORNIA AND CLEAN UP THE
LIST. OUR MEMBERS ARE ORGAN.
AND. THE SOCIAL EQUITY PROGRAM
THIS SUPPORT THAT IT. WITH THE
CITY. REGULATE AND IS THERE.
TWO HOW ARE WE TO RESPECT THOSE
LOCAL READY HAVE A DOT. AND DO
THEIR WORK THE DAVE DOT I WAS
PUSHING THEM BACK AND CREATE I
THIS ORDER ARE WE. BOB WHAT
THAT IS FOR OUR OUR LICENSE.
THE TALKING ABOUT LORDS ONLINE
CHAT ROOMS AND THERE ARE THANK
YOU LATER BY THE BY THE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES. I WAS THE
FIRST TIME THE STATE WERE GIVEN
THAT AUTHORITY. TEAM TO PUT
MORE COPS. I. THAT OFFICE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS DONE ENOUGH I
WILL CONTINUE TO PUSH AND
DIRECT TO. I EAGLE OPERATORS I.
AT WHAT POINT B. GET RID OF
THAT MARKET THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HAVE A- AT
LOGISTICS- THINK MOST. HE SAID
I WOULD LIKE TO JUST A. ONCE I
THINK ARE IMPORTANT ACTUALLY
ONE THAT'S A NEW. THE. ALL THE
GOOD REASONS WHY WE ARE IN THE
AND WE ARE AND WE'RE SEEING THE
PROSPECT OF TONY LET US IN THE
INDUSTRY. REALLY THAT WE CAN DO
SOMETHING AS AS A LEGISLATURE
IS PUT MORE. UNFORCED ATTEMPT
TO THE LAST TWO BUDGET CYCLE
I'M SORRY THAT THE CENTER OF
THE CHAIR OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE HAD TO LEAVE EARLY-
WE'VE TRIED. STRENUOUSLY TO PUT
MORE MONEY IN AND HAVE NOT BEEN
SUCCESSFUL THE MONEY THAT'S
NECESSARY. ANYBODY WHO
QUESTIONS THAT THE ENFORCEMENT
RESOURCES ARE NOT NEARLY.
ENOUGH TO DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE
I'M I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT
SLIGHTLY DISAGREEING. WITH A
COMMENT MADE EARLIER-
INCENTIVES TO CITIES TO HAVE A
TO ADOPT ORDINANCES TO SALAS
RETAIL COULD COULD BE USED AS A
AS A LEVERAGE TO GET THEM. THE
MONEY FOR FORCING COULD BE USED
AS A LEVERAGE TO GET THEM TO-
TO ADOPT LOCAL ORDINANCES I
WOULD ALSO SAY THAT EVEN THOUGH
THEY MAY NOT HAVE A LOCAL
ORDINANCE. IN THOSE CITIES THAT
DON'T HAVE A LOCAL ORDINANCE
ARE A LOT OF THE ILLEGAL
OPERATOR. AND SO WE DO NEED
ENFORCEMENT HAPPENING IN THOSE
LOCATIONS AS WELL- BECAUSE THEY
ARE COMPETITION FOR THOSE WHO
ARE LEGALLY OPERATE. THE LAST
POINT I WOULD MAKE SOMETHING
HAS NOT BEEN RAISED UP UNTIL
TWO YEARS AGO THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY WAS ALSO INVOLVED IN
HELP- AND CBT THAT WAS DERIVED
FROM HIM- WITH FORTY PART OF
OUR OF OUR MARKETING. AND THAT
WAS TAKEN AWAY FROM US IN THE
REGULATIONS- IN LARGE PART
BECAUSE POPS BEFORE DIDN'T
EXCLUDED HIM FROM FROM FROM
CANNABIS- WE ARE NOW BOYS- IN
YOUR HOUSE WITH LEGISLATION TO
RESTORE ON THAT AUTHORITY NOT
JUST TO CANNABIS BUT TO THE
INDUSTRY AS A WHOLE- WE THINK
THAT WILL GO A LONG WAY TOWARDS
HELPING TO- COUNTER SOME OF THE
LOSS IN JOBS THAT WE'RE SEEING
BECAUSE OF THE PROBLEM WITH.
WITH THE CAMERAS INDUSTRY WITH
HOPE THAT THE LEGISLATURE WILL
ADOPT THE HIM CHANGES AND
ENTHUSIASTICALLY AND. VERY
QUICKLY COME THE FIRST OF THE
YEAR. THANK YOU WHICH WHARTON.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
RICH MILLER. HAVEN'T SEEN ANY
PATIENT SPEAK TODAY SO I'M AS
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE PATIENTS
I HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY THIS.
I'VE BEEN UNDER MEDICAL CARE
FOR FORTY FIVE YEARS UP UNTIL
ABOUT EIGHT YEARS AGO AND I
SWEAR OFF ALL LESTER MEDICINE
BECAUSE THE WESTERN MEDICINE I
WAS GIVEN WAS ACTUALLY KILLING
ME- I HAD A SERIOUS ACCIDENT
AND TWO THOUSAND SIX I A FIVE.
THE CONDITIONS THAT QUALIFY
MUSETTE MEDICAL CANNABIS
PATIENTS. PERPIGNAN THE ROBERT
C. IS NUMBER ONE AND TWO
THOUSAND SIX I HAD A VERY.
ACCIDENT WERE I WANT OF USING A
WALKER AND A CANE. AT THAT TIME
THEY STARTED LEARN ME UP WITH
PHARMACEUTICALS AT THE END OF
MY PHARMACEUTICAL USED IN TWO
THOUSAND LEFT OUT ELEVEN I WAS
ON FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
MEDICATIONS A MONTH. I'VE GONE
DOWN TO FORTY WHO- I HAD
DROPPED FORTY FIVE POUNDS DOWN
TO A HUNDRED AND TEN POUNDS.
THOSE USING CANES AND WALKERS
TO GET AROUND. ANNOUNCED TO ME
THERE WAS NOTHING THEY COULD DO
FOR ME THEY WERE TELLING ME I
WAS INTRACTABLE THE
PHARMACEUTICAL FOR A LONGER
WORKING. A TURN TO CANNABIS AND
I'D USE FAN OF THIS BEFORE AND
I HELPED OTHER MEDICAL PATIENTS
USED CANNABIS. WE DIDN'T
CONSIDER MYSELF A PATIENT. WAS
AT THAT TIME I REALIZED HOW
IMPORTANT CANNABIS WAS TO ME IN
MY LIFE. I CAN SAY NOW. I'VE
BEEN EIGHT YEARS PHARMACEUTICAL
FREE I DON'T EVEN USES SO MUCH
AS AN ASPIRIN EVERYTHING IS
TREATED HOLISTICALLY WITH
CANNABIS. AND I DO USE T. H. C.
A. WHICH IS NON PSYCHOACTIVE.
HAS NOT BEEN ACTIVATED SO IF
YOU WERE TO TEST ME. I WOULD
TEST X. LEE HIGH AS YOU CAN SEE
RIGHT NOW I AM NOT MEDICATED AT
ALL. I HAVE ALL MY COGNITIVE
ABILITIES YES IF YOU WERE TO
USE THIS TEST MY TOLERANCE
LEVELS WOULD BE THROUGH THE
ROOF. BECAUSE I TAKE TWO
THOUSAND MILLIGRAMS OF THC A.
DAY ALONG WITH TWO THOUSAND
MILLIGRAMS CBV. SO GOING
FORWARD HOW THIS IS IMPACTED ME
IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE I MADE SIX
FIGURES A YEAR. ONCE I GOT
HEALED IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN I
COULD NOT GO BACK TO MY JOB.
THE JOB THAT I CREATED THE
CONGLOMERATION OF PRINTING
COMPANIES WHICH ENTAILED
THIRTEEN DIFFERENT COMPANIES
WHICH I WAS THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
BOARD BUT MY DRECTORS WOULD
NOT LET ME COME BACK TO WORK
BECAUSE I WAS USING MEDICAL
CANNABIS BECAUSE WE HAD FEDERAL
CONTRACTS. THIS IS THIS IS
SIMPLY DESTROYED MY LIFE AND
MADE IT VERY HARD FOR ME TO
SURVIVE IN LIFE BECAUSE I NOW
CAN ONLY MAKE THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR BECAUSE
I'M FORCED TO GO WORK IN TH
MEDICAL CANNABIS INDUSTRY
BECAUSE MY INDUSTRY AFTER
TWENTY YEARS WILL NO LONGER
HIRE ME AND CONSIDERED A RISK.
SO THIS IS VERY IMPERATIVE THAT
WE MOVE FORWARD ON THIS AND
THAT WE ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND
WE FIGURE AN ADEQUATE WAY OF
MEASURING TOLERANCES. THIS
WITHOUT THAT. WE'RE DOOMED TO
FAIL HER. AND WE NEED TO MOVE
FORWARD. AND IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE GRANT ACCESS THROUGH
THE ENTIRE STATE. BECAUSE
65270% OF THE STATE DOES NOT
HAVE ACCESS. EVEN IN MY OWN
COUNTY A PLASTER COUNTY WHERE
WE SPENT EIGHTEEN MONTHS DOING
SURVEYS WE HAD 73% APPROVAL
RATE IN THAT COMMUNITY. TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH CANNABIS BUT OR
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS DECIDED
NOT TO MOVE FORWARD. SO WE NEED
TO REMOVE THE STIGMA WE NEED TO
STEP FORWARD WE NEED TO GET
SOME ADEQUATE TESTING FOR
TOLERANCES. AND TO MOVE FORWARD
AND I APPRECIATE ALL YOUR TIME
IN THE MOVING FORWARD THIS IS
LONG OVERDUE. AND I AM VERY
APPRECIATIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE AND THANKS
FOR THE TESTIMONY OF TO AT THE-
VERY INFORMATIVE THANK YOU.
OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT. SEEN NONE
OF HEARING IS ADJOURNED THANK
YOUALL FOR BEING HERE AND
THANK YOU FOR THE VALUABLE
INFORMATION